the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess
club even the best AIS would fear the
near-perfect play on display at the US
Women's and US Open championships in St
Louis no pieces are safe when facing
this dangerous field they'll take your
pawns your Rooks and your Bishops
Carissa y played like a machine
annihilating all resistance to knit a
victory and remain in Cole Fabiano
caruana sure looks like he'll be
back-to- back us jamp after drawing his
game to stay in clear first the front
runers are pulling away but the future
is not yet written day seven of
Relentless chess coming up
[Music]
next
welcome back chess fans to day seven of
the US chess championships and US
Women's chess Championships held at the
St Louis chess club we start a day in
the Central West End where the players
are battling for position in this
coveted National Championship it's been
a fantastic event so far let's go to the
studio and start the
action welcome to St Louis the home of
Chess in America as the St Louis chess
club proudly presents the US and US
Women's chess championships we are past
the halfway mark As round seven begins
[Music]
now hello and welcome everyone thank you
for joining us I'm kaarina yova and I am
here with yaser Sahan Kate the halfway
point has passed and it's been wonderful
yeah fantastic games incredible fighting
spirit I love it me too hello everyone
and Welcome to our show the 2023
national championships have been great
and we are seeing separation the top two
ladies are running away with the ladies
Championship with plus four scores
pretty impressive stuff and in the open
section we have a clear first clear
second but Kate do the honors and tell
us the current standings after seven six
rounds of okay so let's take a look and
let's start with the women section so
standings after round six two leaders
Karis s and beim toir janova they've
been just storming through the
tournament with Five Points incredible
performance and third place clear third
place for arena crash with four points
really impressive stuff by Carissa and
Beerman tell us about the open section
in the open section not my much have
changed since yesterday we still have a
leader Fabiano caruana with four and a
half points out of six but he's closely
followed by hnan with four points and
then there is a two-way tie for a third
place Wes Lea and lenier Dominguez with
three and a half points and tell us
about the format for uh these two
national championships we play two 12
player R Robins which means each player
plays everybody else in their in their
respective section we play classical
chess the time control is 9 20 minutes
for first 40 moves followed by 30
minutes for rest of the game and 30
second increment from move one players
are not allowed to agree on draw they
cannot even offer a draw and we have
traditional scoring system one point for
win half a point for a draw and zero
points for loss as we pass the halfway
mark tell us more about the remaining
schedule C so we always play one round a
day today round 7 we always start at
1:20 p.m. Center time tomorrow round 8
and then everybody has her rest day then
three more rounds and if necessary there
will be playoffs on Wednesday October
18th wonderful and Christian we're
wonderful to have you in studio and tell
us about the leaders and their road
ahead good to see you guys good to see
you it was a timid round yesterday
especially in the open section but I
have to say the ladies definitely
brought the heat in yesterday's battles
so let's take a look after six rounds
where do we stand in terms of standings
but also highlight the road ahead of our
leaders in the ladies section as we can
see Karissa Yip and beim toir NOA are
creating some separation compared to uh
their followers as you can see Arena
Crush now she's one point behind the two
ladies she was half a point yesterday
but she was unable to win that end game
against ruang Yen and unfortunately
right now for her she's one full point
behind the leaders let's take a look at
karissa's road ahead one of the
co-leaders in the Ladi section as you
can see just an incredible score five
points out of six possible points in
round seven she's playing a struggling
player I have to say Talia cantes a good
opportunity for her to potentially get
the sole lead or extend for lead in
round eight she's playing atusa por
kashian and in round n a big battle
against the two-time national champion
Nazi P kidza definitely an accessible
road ahead in the next three rounds for
Karissa and what about her Co leader
that is beim toir jonova woman
Grandmaster beim toir jonova also
sitting pretty on Five Points out of six
in round seven against Nazi pizza that's
a big battle right there but I have to
say Nazi has been struggling in this
event hiccups here and there round eight
against Anna zansi that's a player that
she struggles against and in round nine
against ruy yangyang a very uh difficult
road ahead in the next three rounds for
beim and what about about the open
standings in that one we have a sole
leader the defending Champion Fabiano
Carana sitting pretty on four points and
a half out of six as I was mentioning
nothing has changed because yesterday we
had six draws out of six games possible
Hans Nan still in so second place half a
point behind the leader and let's
highlight Fabiano's road ahead for the
next three rounds this is a big one
today against Ray Robson with the black
pieces this one is not going to to be an
easy task for Fabiano round eight
against Shanklin and round nine that's
that's the big matchup we are all
expecting Fabiano versus Hans Neiman and
speaking of Hans let's take a look at
his road ahead as well I have to say
this is a big one in round seven with
the white pieces against the struggling
Andrew Tang he needs to try and score a
victory and if he does so he has a good
chance to potentially catch up Fabiano
Carana maybe even surpass him who knows
but he needs to win in today's match up
round eight against Ray Robson and round
nine again that big clash between
himself and the defending Champion
Fabiano Carana guys round every single
round we have so many exciting matchups
what are you guys looking uh forward to
well let's take a look at all the
pairings Kate do the honor and tell our
audience what they can expect for this
round seven let's start with the ladies
let's take a look so we have Crush who
is in the clear third place and she will
try to take advantage of struggling esar
game uh to maybe catch up with the
leaders absolutely Arena knows this is
one she needs to win with white then we
have you playing Yan Lee playing
zatonski that's uh that's a big match
right there Alice Lee and Anna zatonski
toir janova the leader playing former US
champion pit another key matchup of
today abrahamian playing Pur kashian and
then we have Yip playing cantes also big
matchup and uh for the open section all
the prings round seven will bring games
Robson against the leader Karana Hans
Neiman against Andrew Tang we talked
about that game exactly Hans will
definitely try to win this game to catch
up with Karana then we have sof playing
Jong Wesley just on the outside and
Jeffrey's A little vulnerable so
Wesley's going to try to push with the
white pieces then we have a game of
elite and experienced players Dominguez
playing aronian then SCH playing Mishra
and savian playing against shankland
very very nice and these players have
been fighting very very hard you
mentioned the No No draw offers what are
they fighting for in the ladies very
generous price Fund
$152,000 in the women's section first
place winning 40,000 second place 30,000
and third place $20,000 and all players
receives receed prize money with 12
plays winning $44,000 and in the open
section K we have even bigger money here
$250,000 price fund with first Place
winning 60,000 second place 45,000 and
third place 35,000 all the way to 12th
Place which is I believe 6000 6,000 and
there we see the World Chess Hall of
Fame where the tournament site and
Fabiano our tournament leader he's up
against Ray Robson and I have to say Ray
started terribly like just miserably but
Ray put together a brilliancy against
Jeffrey Shan and you know when you play
one of your career best games because
that will be in Ray robson's book of
career best games you start to feel
better about yourself and Fabby knows as
an Olympic teammate of his Ray can score
against anybody absolutely absolutely
and he scored so many important
victories at the olympiads I remember
this game against vukov I think when he
played his first olympi Russ against
Russia yeah what an incredible game that
was he won that one in uh a tactical
melee but I have to say Fabby was a bit
distressed yesterday because we missed
something and he missed something as
well he had a great move at one point in
his game that would have given him a
great advantage against Sam Sean
yesterday you know how he found it
Bishop E3 this game with Bishop B3 yes
yes he had the D4 move he had that D4
move at one point in the game maybe I
will show it to you later Ray is late
and Fabby is looking around waiting man
I got to start your clock they they they
hit the cowbell and there you go but I
know the the players have to get wanded
they come through security maybe there's
a little bit of a Jam at the security
desk there but you were saying continue
uh Fabby missed a key moment he missed
he missed a key moment I will show it to
you later and when we will have uh some
time because he was very distressed at
dinner he uh looked at it he understood
that he had a great opportunity to
potentially score a victory in that one
and he wasn't very happy about it okay
Kate give me your minds said I'm looking
at the game between Hans Neiman and
Andrew Tang you have to imagine you're
coming into this round you have the
white pieces against a lower rated
player and you're thinking to
yourself I've got to score I've got to
win this game I should win this game how
do you approach this game when you're in
that circumstance yeah with having white
pieces you want to go into some
complicated games because you see your
player is your opponent is not very
confident in his game uh so I think we
can expect some maybe even some
Novelties because maybe you remember
when Hans was in the studio saying that
he got inspired from a recent game at a
tournament at the world juniors and he
used that inspiration against Leon
aronian exactly and there we do see as I
actually correctly guessed just a second
let me give myself Pat myself on the
back for that one Ray Robson going
through security as we we've got the
most sophisticated wanding
equipment definitely making sure that
players have no electronic devices no
watches nothing on themselves so there
can be no doubt about them cheating at
the game and that's the second one the
he has the first one and that's the
military grade one as you can see the
one with the the thermal one yeah the
military thermal one yes I got to put on
the night glasses night yes yes to see
what kind of light rays might be
emanating from Ray Robson as he gets
into the tournament Hall again just
turning our attention to Hans Neiman and
Andrew Tang for a
moment you know no Joko piano today
which at least for Hans as he essays uh
the ru Lopez by the way what a beautiful
playing Hall I'm just always amazed
every day we see the same playing Hall
and I'm just speechless that's because
we have played in some tournament Halls
that we're not really that proud of
basement and uh other places let's just
say uh Bishop A4 and Knight E7 by Andrew
um I think they call this the really
taking time to make a move he's stying
his shoes bringing water right uh uh
Andrew I think is the first to try to
surprise his opponent with the move
Knight E7 well okay the idea is pretty
straightforward you're defending the
Knight which defends the pawn and you're
planning to play G7 G6 Bishop G7 in the
very near future I I have it in mind
that shakar
midaro uh Champions the black site and
lios pores in his day but to be fair to
lios he played just about everything
under the sun uh just uh a great
theoretician Leos I don't know what the
current um state of theory is uh with
Knight E7 but that I played this opening
several times for white and I like it
it's very active but I know there are a
lot of direct ways that black can get
also very reasonable position exactly so
you were saying that when you approach a
game where you're a big favorite and
your opponent is looking to throw you
off well Andrew kind of did that you
guessed uh his his strategy uh correctly
uh as well uh let me just go to Ray
Robson versus Fabby whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa look at this E4 C5 wow I don't
remember last time seeing Sicilian
played by Fab by Fabby uh
that's a that's a surprise for sure as
he uh is thinking
to out Fox Ray in the opening uh this is
this is going to be remember Leon Aron
he also played Sicilia in the previous
round and saying that you know sometimes
you need to practice your new opening in
actually high stakes tournaments not
just when playing Blitz and just playing
with friends ex yeah but when you're
really being tested severely in a
classical tournament like the national
championships but boy I must say
uh this is a stunner uh D7 D6 I'm just
going to go quickly Sam Sean Sam feel
like he needs to win this game with
black I mean his opening Choice
definitely points to that but that's a
very risky situation right exactly
playing D6 maybe he believes that Hans
has a great opportunity to score against
Andrew and he doesn't want to see him uh
next next to him as a leer for Co lead I
don't know uh
r ray is not not somebody you want to
play with right now though D7 D6 and Ray
is just thinking to himself okay if I do
play D2 D4 now I do remember in the
candidates where it was one of those
last round games that um um Fabby was
playing against Sergey and he needed to
win and then he essayed not the nidorf
but this uh classical yes uh with Bishop
G5 E7
E6 Sergey ended up playing one of the
greatest games of his career and uh
sacrificed a rook and won that game won
the candidates went on to play Magnus in
the 2018 uh World Championship in New
York City great stuff but uh help me out
here coach you you you've worked with um
with Fabby when he play no when he plays
the Sicilian what is uh his mindset well
I've seen Fabby play the Four Knights
not this D6 as much like he essay E6
followed by Knight F6 and Knight C6
quite a few times in fact whenever he
needs to win he usually plays it when he
needs to win I remember this game
against I believe it was in Norway chess
last year against Arian tari yes he had
to win with the black pieces or at least
that's how he approached it and he
played the Sicilian the Four Knights
with Knight to C6 this leads to
completely wild positions right Knight
B5 Knight A6 um very very dangerous
positions for both sides but this one I
haven't seen him play in a very very
long time as you were mentioning maybe
that was the last game against kakin
going all the way back to 2018 so that's
quite a while back now we're going to
have to wait and see I do believe that
Ray played a move or at least he was
about to play a move we haven't received
it on our
um Ray seems to be uh he's still in the
tank okay still thinking so he's
thinking if I play an open Sicilian uh
what will Fabby have prepared for me
because we know Fabby is not bluffing he
he's done he's done his homework if I
play an aen with a C3 you know what will
that bring what type of middle game
position is that going to how can I
deviate should I play D4 and potentially
take with the queen that's a
completely different set of uh middle
game position had a very important game
against Sam shankland I think last us
Championship where he played with Bishop
B5 a very important win exactly he
scored and then you have the bishop B5
check and again a whole different
schematics there as well Christian and
this also plays a little bit against Ray
because we know Ray he likes to think he
likes to get in time trouble situation
make him think as early as move to why
not and that's going to help you with
your goal of getting Ray into time
trouble situation exactly I this is a a
choice made against specifically against
this player okay uh before I turn to the
ladies I did want to just take a quick
Gander at Wesley so versus Jeffrey Jong
because again Wesley is sitting on the
outside at the moment but a wi today
would certainly put some wind in his
sales as uh they play this uh Joko piano
with this early D7 D5 uh if black can
ever get away with this early D5 I think
that just completely neutralizes the
chooko piano we have been seeing a lot
of uh games in this event and many
others with D7 D6 and with A5 and the
complex the complexity of playing A6
Andor as you just mentioned A5 and
number of potential sacrifices after
Bishop G5 H6 Bishop H4 G5 but if you can
ever just get away with with D5 and if
you can just neutralize the position and
say okay this position is even uh then
D7 D5 is going to be very very uh
popular let's turn our attention to the
ladies uh for a moment as we jump into
the game between beum and Nasi Nasi
plays the caroan this will not have been
a surprise whatsoever for beum so she
plays the advance and both players are
heading straight into a very topical
line and want once again uh W I'll
remind you you won a very nice game uh
from the Olympiad uh but you didn't play
it with Knight B3 right you did uh did
something else to be honest I don't
exactly remember the game the move order
but I played a different game with this
KN B3 idea to stop C5 okay uh or maybe
we were considering to even play this
line during the game because the Knight
is doing a very good job there just not
allowing the counterplay on the queen
side yeah from pardon me from Black's
point of view this the center if you
will the D4 E5 it's it really cramps uh
black and you say to yourself where
should this bishop go well it doesn't
have a very good diagonal right uh so
the idea is you want to chip away just
as you said uh black is ready to play C5
if he can if he ever can weaken White's
control of the center the bishop could
go to G7 so from Black's point of view
black needs to play moves like F6 and or
C5 so the usual setups are Knight D7
Queen D7 Queen C7 Bishop G7 and this is
all Theory let's continue Carissa Yip
has just been simply outstanding uh with
a plus four score but she's doing it
with the black pieces can she do it
today with Talia using the same weapon
that she already played in this
tournament this bishop D7
mhm and uh F2 F3 and the players well I
won't call it an English attack because
that's usually what you do against the
nidorf uh with A7 A6 um Bishop E3
interesting moment right here because as
black you could if you want to transpose
into a dragon right with G7 G6 but then
you are allowing the Yugoslav attack
Queen D2 Bishop
C4 if I'm in black shoes and I don't
want to play the dragon uh E7 E6 E7
because this stuff now is not that scary
for black because you've already played
Bishop to E3 why should I be afraid of
the position after Bishop Bishop E3
Bishop right so you lose the tempo to
attack that pawn no so e E7 E6 Bishop E7
castles and you go into a normal uh
shingan or shanigan variation we have A6
on the board and Karissa wasting no time
A6 a G4 ready to attack let's
go usually we see Queen d2 move before
but just going immediately with G4 so a
kind of a Caris attack but in this case
white has used the tempo F2 F3 um and
here the combination of Bishop and D7
and A7
A6 um that feels awkward to my eyes why
because often times like if we just take
this move back back for a moment um
sorry I apologies I'm just going to do
it like this
A6 uh F3 E6 Bishop E3 Bishop E7 G4 many
cases we're really not that afraid of
the move G5 because we have the square
D7 so we could go for example Knight C6
uh G5 and this is all Theory but in the
current position the bishop is actually
on D7 and that makes the move G4 that
much more attractive for the white
player because G5 means that you're
going to have to play Knight H5 whether
you like it or not I think one thing
that white I mean black can try is to
develop The Rook on C8 very quickly to
try to Target the Knight on C8 C3 pardon
me okay no worries and if we do go a
little bit nuts I have to go Knight H5
okay and here we pause for a moment
because we do you know we can't really
play F4 cuz you could take and maybe
take on F4 but uh we could slow play
this with Queen D2 and uh the idea here
is to play Bishop E2 and maybe F4 you
could you may have to play E5 I'm not
sure how you like this I like Queen A5
but it is dangerous for like with that
Knight on the edge of the board jump in
uh if you don't mind Christian with this
theoretical du going on between Karissa
and Talia the combination of A6 and
Bishop D7 I'm not a big fan yes not a
big fan but it has been played quite a
few times um obviously the idea is that
with A6 and the bishop already on D7 I
can play the move B5 early on so perhaps
this is her idea in this position the
Knight on C6 is no longer on pre with
the bishop on D7 that's the main plan
now the question is how are you going to
respond to this immediate threat right
because I'm going G5 I'm following it up
with F4 and you're not yet developed
right and if you have to defend this
Knight on H5 for example let's say you
make a random move Rook to C8 G5 was so
Random Wasn't So Random deep well well
considered okay I'm not going to
play5 Rook C8 a random move Rook C8
that's a normal move right G5 Knight H5
and now I have ideas of f4 right well
I'm not sure Knight takes D4 Knight F4 I
don't know uhuh so this is how you want
to play it take and then take on F4 this
is your idea well I'm not sure and then
to play like this with a pawn down
perhaps right or well I'm not sure about
that either but but uh yeah we were just
thinking that the night on H5 just drive
it to H5 and play Queen D2 you can also
do that yes you can also just play it
slow with Queen to D2 but if F4 works
and it provokes G6 well then we're happy
I will go F5 at some point I will open
you up your Bishop is going is committed
right now to the square G6 now I have
much more of a control over the D5
Square because you don't want to combine
G6 with E6 right you're weakening too
many dark squares around your king so
definitely something to look out for G4
was the last move I'm seeing Karissa at
least both of the players right now seem
to be out of their preparation so that
means we're going to have a very
exciting game in this one but guys hold
on hold on just G4 apologies so just
give me what is the most popular moves
after G4 what has black played most Al
H6 this this is a pretty big sideline
big sideline uh not that many games only
27 games in this position this is move
eight in a sicilian you generally have
much more games being played yes for
sure 27 games it hasn't been explored as
much H6 to stop G5 immediately is one of
the most I would say natural choices in
the position right because you do have
to spend some time after that to go H4
Rook to G1 get the Rook off the H file
because otherwise you cannot recapture
with the H Pawn and then go G5 right so
these are the type of details that these
players will have to uh navigate yes for
the next few moves H6 and then Queen to
D2 H4 is also move let's see Queen to D2
how in general do you usually develop
your pieces also there's a slight issue
with the bishop on D7 because the Knight
cannot return
right very often whenever you get hit by
the way Knight takes D4 was played so
nothing that we just discussed and right
now we're slowly slowly entering new
territory still three games have been
played by the way all of themen takes D
takes D absolutely makes a lot of sense
right you want to go long castle Yeah
well if you can play the Scandinavian
without having to suffer the consequence
of Knight C3 take with a queen and after
Queen takes D4 she played Queen takes D4
makes a lot of sense and uh okay Bishop
C6 and E5 were the two moves that have
been played in this position most yeah
Bishop well again there's only three
games Bishop C6 two of them and E5 and
by the way I don't actually recognize
except Josh whin we recognize Josh whin
in 1992 okay I was yeah I was around
Searching for Bobby fer Searching for
Bobby Fischer that's 992 and the last
game was actually played in 2005 and I
do believe that is some sort of a
correspondence game because once again I
don't recognize the names um seems like
correspondence this has been tried not
so much in actual practice so the ladies
I would say right now they're kind of in
novel territory for both of them whoever
is the better player whoever is feeling
this type of positions better is going
to win this one and you were going to
you were anxious to show us another uh
position uh oh I was just going to go
back to this uh Hans versus Andrew it's
such a consequential game for standings
right C3 and we were discussing this
generally this Knight E7 is coupled with
the idea of G6 right G6 put a bishop PA
G7 Knight to G6 was Andrew's Choice D4
take and now Knight takes D4 already a
pretty significant surprise I don't
think I've ever seen Knight G6 being
played in this position yes yes so black
surprised first but then white Hans
decided to surprise back because
obviously he knows he played C3 the most
natural move is to take with a c Pawn
clear take with a c Pawn get the uh the
Knight to C3 but then he takes with the
Knight and this has been played only
once in 2022 a decent grandmas game but
only played once and let's take a look
at what has happened Knight takes D4 C
takes D4 and the engine is saying that
already white has significant advantage
in the position and I have to say Knight
to D4 is a very good practical Choice
mhm why you might ask the best move is
Bishop to C5 okay Bishop to E3 very easy
to see and right now you're already
having to face some serious threats you
cannot just hang around and go short
castle that's a blunder because of
Knight takes C6 so already you have to
calculate and you have to play moves
such as Knight to E5 the other Knight to
E5 the best moves in the position what
I'm trying to say they don't General
connect very well with the ideas that
you had that you knew from back home of
playing this move Knight to E7 Knight to
G6 Bishop C5 develop everything play D5
at the right moment and definitely get
this Knight most likely to E5 not the
other Knight to E5 and after Knight D5 I
can go Queen to E2 things get very
serious very quickly and it seems like
Hans perhaps knew better this idea he
got surprised but perhaps has analyzed
this position at home and knows exactly
what he's doing right now he's
borderline winning I'm look I'm I'm not
exaggerating when I'm saying this this
is borderline winning because I have the
center your knight on H6 is going to get
hit either by F4 or H4 I have a couple
of opportunities to do that and if you
don't get D5 in very quickly you're in
trouble it I find myself stunned but
that Andrew would have such a bad
position after miror 7even moves I mean
of course you look at the pardon me I'll
bring it up on my screen as well you
look at the central pawns it's really
bad the central Pond Duo D4 and E4 uh
but it's really about the fact that
you're not playing D7 D5 and either
provoking E4 E5 yaser I have to say I
just don't understand this because
Knight G6 has to be home preparation of
course and H made a very normal move d4
well also C3 is very normal I'm much
more used to seeing by the way D7 D6 D2
D4 Bishop to D7 and then later you're
you're seriously your very next move
you're playing Knight G6 because you've
got E5 well protected but the
combination of Knight G6 and capturing
twice on D4 that's very strange because
again if you're not hitting the Centra
Pond Duo right away with moves like D5
then I'm just going to play Knight C6
Knight C3 castles and what is this
Knight doing on yeah and Andrew is
thinking in this position because he
already lost about 15 minutes after 94
he started thinking so that's how I know
that Han
surprised Andrew with Knight hd4 again
right it's easy to miss but look it's so
early on you shouldn't be missing Knight
it's a it exists you have to analyze it
exactly especially if you know you're
going to be playing Knight G6 I mean
that's a risky line if you don't know it
you get punished at this level yeah if I
were in Andrew shoes I would have been
sitting there saying well why am am I
helping my opponent with the move Knight
takes D4 maybe I'm not a big fan of this
position Bishop B7 castles castles
Knight F5 the Knight really looks really
good on F5 and I definitely do think
whites were choice but at least I
have I have a secret smile that's going
on you're not going to get Knight C3 and
a nice position for your knight your
Pawn on C3 in fact is not great but
helping the pawn
going to D4 that seems very contrarily
to me so it's so easy for white to
develop just Castle Knight C3 fluid easy
you're not going to spend much time on
making those moves no exactly Knight C3
castles and I very very seriously start
to think about F4 F5 and when you say
very big Advantage I believe you're
Christian then what else is it's close
to uh 1 point and a half Advantage at
this point that's close to decisive
objectively at least right and it just
feels so much easier and in the game of
Fabiano what did Ray Ray come up with he
decided to go with Bishop to B5 which he
BL it kind of makes sense he blame he
usually plays D4 he's usually an open
Sicilian type of player but he blame
because he knew Fabby has something
prepared and you look you don't want to
fight his preparation when you have your
own preparation when you don't have your
own preparation in uh before the game
that's when you want to deviate as early
as possible that's exactly what he did
Bishop to B5 Knight to D7 we sort of
expected and now already after Bishop to
B5 Knight D7 we understand Fab is
playing this game for a victory with the
black pieces because Bishop to D7 is
considered to be just fine for black
close to equalizing if you know exactly
what you're doing Knight to D7 is
throwing the gauntlet keeping more
pieces on the board because if you do
take on D7 later on you're giving me the
two Bishops so in general white doesn't
give uh the two Bishops and chooses The
Retreat on E2 Knight F6 Knight C3 G6 and
this is what we have right now B5 a
takes B5 and a takes B6 excuse me and
Knight takes B6 and this is sort of
well-known Theory black is going to try
to go A5 A4 and then um create some sort
of an attack on the pawn B2 and at the
right moment hopefully he's going to be
able to or at least black hopes that
he's going to be able to uh exchange the
weakness the a pawn is the weak Ness in
Black scam for the pawn on B2 and
equalize like such these are the type of
dynamics that go into Play Bishop to E3
sometimes white even looks at ideas of
opening up the center with a move d4
later on in the position so for example
Bishop to E3 Queen to C7 I do think that
you have to worry about if you do go A5
some ideas of E5 now that pawn on C5 is
under attack this type of exchanges and
with favor white yeah unclear but you
have to be thinking you have to have
those in the back of your mind um A5 is
one of the moves Queen to C7 is another
one of the moves Bishop to B7 has been
played as well so again it's all about
who knows the position better and I have
a feeling Fabby has analyzed this at
home as you mentioned he's not bluffing
no when he plays when he's ready to play
these type of situations you know that
he analyzed this probably not the night
before but maybe before the tournament
maybe this is his weapon to play for a
win before the tournament so definitely
an interesting ring coming from Fabiano
we haven't seen him as a employ this
type of openings before so this will
lead to an exciting game thank you
Christian and Kate where would you like
to take us I want to take a look around
all the games that are being played in
the open section all right uh well let's
jump into the game of Sam Sean as the
two
Sams face are going see another Rook
game today oh for sure yeah what's the
over and under on a rook ending in a Sam
Shanklin game well we'll take the over
uh Bishop G5 uh semi Slavs uh variation
H7 H6 Bishop takes uh F6 none of these
uh crazy Gambit Bob vinck Pawn
sacrifices with Bishop H4 but Bishop
takes F6 Queen takes F6 E3 white gives
up uh the two Bishops for lead in
development as well as this bishop uh on
C8 players are still in theory let's
continue our look around uh darush
versus Mishra and this is a French and
uh I I have faced it as black uh on
multiple uh games um um uh and I always
loved playing the black side I 100 yeah
I have 100% score 100% always won well
now you know why I like playing it with
black I've always won and
uh nobody and I mean nobody played the
move Bishop F4 against I played it twice
with white and I also have 100% as white
as white in this position wow we're
going to have a Clash of Titans when we
we sit down together Bishop B5 my
opponents have played against me as well
as Bishop E3 but for my my experience
Bishop F4 is new after Bishop F4 uh uh
Mish played Knight F6 which makes
perfect sense where a pawn up after all
let's let's hold on to it Bishop B5 now
and now Knight
D5
um black is trying to force that
exchange because if white decides to
exchange the knights then I'm very happy
to
recapture Pawn Yeah but on the other
hand thereare I ask you play Bishop B5 I
play Bishop D7 and you're not really I
don't think you you're ever really
threatening to take uh I don't see how
Bishop B Bishop F4 and Bishop B5
coordinate with one another unless can
D5 yeah that might that's one of the
typical moves in this opening right we
want to push forward to kind of control
that Center okay Mishra did play the
move Knight D5 we're caught up um with
the
play and let's just remind ourselves
where these two players and I know they
both of them looking uh for a victory
they're tight for the fifth place well
actually darou is a half a point behind
Mishra right so darush is really Mishra
sitting on 50% at one moment he had that
moment in the sun he was at the top of
the Cross table m in very early days
right uh but he would have told him
going into this event that after more
than half of the event you're going to
be uh in the half of the field I think
he would have
yeah no absolutely he's a come on he's
14 years old he's in his debut of the
national champion not the lowest rated
player because that's Andrew Tang the
winner of the US Open but still his
worst bottom in terms of rating of
course definitely his overperforming in
this event big big time uh jump in on on
the theoretical dispute that's taking
place here Christian uh first of all
what's the name of this Gambit it's the
French it's just the wi War
win Gambit variation win variation is
what the database is telling me Knight
to D5 apparently is a very rare move
Bishop to D7 being the main line okay in
this position Bishop to D7 Queen to D2
is a pawn sacrifice but I will take that
pawn at some point I will go long Castle
Rook to E1 and then you're not going to
be able to defend that pawn on e4 for
much longer so Knight to D5 is the first
sprinkle definitely something that he
prepared at home because he has an hour
and 30 minutes and this definitely
stopped Darius because right now he's
trying to understand okay what am I
doing now right Bishop to D2 makes a lot
of sense right does it really you don't
want to take on D5 I don't want to take
on D5 that's that's pretty obvious do
you want to give up the dark Square
Bishop probably not as well where do you
put the bishop G3 or a D2 to my eyes
makes the most sense right G3 or Knight
B6 great I'll bring my Bishop back to f
one and just yeah now if you want to
play A4 you play A4 okay take on C5 and
Bishop E3 At Last I I feel like I
finally developed my Bishop my took me
took me forever to get the bishop out
into the game have a couple of ways to
uh defend that but let's start with Rook
to d8 Queen E2 all right kind of
standard
stuff Bishop 2 f8 seems to be a move
well the point
I go Bishop to f8 this is a bit yeah but
your knight was on D5 and it was kind of
enclosing my Bishop on C1 now your
Knight's on B6 and maybe I play C4 here
and C4 really yeah well your knight is
on B6 and it's not g to okay taking it
away from B6 Rook
D1 Rook D1 Rook B8 I
think interesting that is true now I'm
starting to put some pressure yeah yeah
the a pawn has become an asset an asset
exactly it blocks the pawn on B2 and
this right now is the main weakness in
the position good point while the last
10 moves the a pawn was the main
weakness in the position now again
defended by the bishop Pawn C6 very
nicely defended and it would take you a
lot of time to go Bishop to D3 Bishop to
C2 first of all you cannot do that
because you lose the pawn on B2 Rook to
A1 and only at that point you will have
enough resources even threaten my Pawn
on A4 right is very difficult to get to
it this is the differentiator in the
position perhaps Fabiano understands
that at least with the black pieces and
it's so difficult to win games
especially against Mighty opposition
such as Ray Robson but at least he got
something he got an imbalance in the
position and he played Queen B7 so he
did not go Knight B6 okay Bishop C4
Queen B7 yeah it was strange in that
line where I felt I finally did
something good developed my Bishop to E3
it turned out well it wasn't that great
here again as as white I'd probably be
tempted to capture on on C5 and you know
just uh Define the structure for a
moment maybe and offer Queen trade Queen
B3 okay then you have we pawns on C5 and
A5 oh well he's not going to trade
Queens he's going to go Knight B6 and
the DI Bishop takes F7 though oh that
might be a problem now that's upon you
you
right I mean you're still taking it back
but that's not enough uh take take take
I can always take on C5 or on A5 okay
you have some Queen D1 so I have to be
ready for that but Queen E6 check is a
move as well you don't have enough on
this side don't do this yeah Bishop E3
right but one let take a look at the
open standings after that draw that we
just saw between leevon and
lineer so we still have Fabiano with
four and a half points but Len are now
caught up with hun neand because he has
four points absolutely and if I'm in the
top standing as I'm seeing leavon
struggling making draws I'm like good
that's one guy you know like uh don't
have to worry about tell me about the
game of Hans Neeman because uh Hans was
gifted a huge Advantage out of the
opening is that still the case Christian
oh yes for sure but not as big anymore
because it seems like Andrew is trying
to fight fight his way back we've seen
this move Rook to B1 and now the bishop
is on A2 and perhaps this last move came
as a surprise right you were not
thinking that black can actually play
the move B5 you're losing a pawn but in
fact A2 is hanging the bishop Pawn A2 is
hanging so I have time to go B5 and then
you know what I'm going to do next I'm
going to play C6 as well cement the
structure as is on that side in the
meantime you have to do something you
have to do something G4 is not uh
intuitively but the bishop was on C2 ah
and he he was able to go well in the
game in the stem game that we were
discussing at the beginning of uh the
show the bishop was on C2 baso Pier
Luigi and Queen on D3 setting up this
nice beautiful ma attack right that's
not the case in this position so Andrew
definitely fighting back trying to crawl
his way out of this uh deep hole that he
put himself out of the opening on the
clock still way behind 21 minutes
against 53 minutes Hans still with a
very nice Advantage at the same time
things are getting a little bit tricky
in the position Rook
A1 okay that is okay you defending A2
but aren't you allowing a pin after for
example Knight Knight B6 Knight B6 yeah
why not and by the way maybe we can uh
look at uh the players because I think
Andrew was ready to make a move he
always looks like he's ready to make a
move
actually there we go uh no no he's not
going to make a move but Knight to B6
does look like a very natural Mo I'm
looking at the position Kate I'm kind of
reminded of open spanish's you know
where where oftentimes in the open
Spanish you're trying to get in the move
C5 and it's a usually it's a big fight
for these two squares on the queen side
C5 and C4 the last move Rook A1 isn't it
just
encouraging uh Knight B6 I mean after
all he play it if you play uh A5 I'm
jumping to C4 and I'm very very grateful
if you take I'm very grateful so I'm
assuming you know I to say I surprised
by more moves even Bishop A2 I wasn't
sure I really understand why to move the
bishop back well back here we were
talking about again stem game where the
bishop could come to C2 you could then
play for queen uh D3 and G4 which
happened Bishop A4 Bishop A2 so he wants
to Target the I think he missed he just
missed B5 B5 uh was not uh and then
suddenly the whole Bishop A2 Rook B1
looks like loss of Tempe right and if
white plays A5 to just block it then
black is very happy for just getting C5
right well and just kind of locking the
the shutting down the queen side too
right yes I I I do understand that C5
Bishop
A3 fighting stuff going on there but I'm
just saying that you know it wasn't what
white wanted when he went uh in for this
whole line and of course I would look to
put the Knight on E6 on a good day here
but let's see what happened because he
did play Rook A1 Knight B6 and again
Hans is has stopped because Hans has two
Bishops right so he wants to have an
open position but suddenly if Andrew is
starting to close that position or even
having a good uh Square for tonight
Bishop B3 on the board so kind of
inviting the same ending that we're
seeing in laner and um leavon game
Bishops of opposite color okay if we
just did the straight forward takes
takes I'm assuming we're going to
recapture with the Rook um both both
sides are happy right I mean the white
white has dark squares black has light
squares I I feel like white is a little
bit happier because of the protected
pass Pawn on E5 but that's that's going
to be hard to win I I mean you know I'm
going to play Bishop to B5 C6 and uh
let's just remind everybody Huns comes
into today's round in second place and
he has he is playing Andrew tank and
then Ray Robson and Fabi
the bottom seat so Hans is thinking I
should win against
Andrew and then Ray Robson and big game
uh in round nine uh but I think hanza
spoiled his a large part of his
Advantage yes yeah it's kind of gone
away yes absolutely and I mean you can
even transition into an opposite color
Bishop uh situation right in which your
attack on the king side via the B1 H7
diagonal is not coming anymore yeah it's
gone yeah it's gone it it truly is gone
because you have to give me the bishop
right we have to go into this uh
position and now you have couple of
options you can take on A4 with either
the queen or The Rook or you can start
with Bishop to A3 as well and try to put
that Bishop on that diagonal at the same
time look I go here I I'm starting to uh
harass you a little bit I'm trying to
exchange pieces I'm trying to get closer
to a draw right exactly Queen to D7
where do you put the queen it doesn't
really matter if you go anywhere I'm
going to go to C6 I'm going to start
playing on the light squares exactly
that's the idea and at some point you
will still have to prove your break as
white are you going to go G4 I don't see
that happening anymore right so how do
you evolve your position how do you make
any progress and I don't see it I think
Knight takes A4 if he plays it he has a
good chance to neutralize Hans uh in
this round exactly i' like to turn our
attention to where some action is uh the
two Sams uh Sam Sean and Sam Shanklin
when we left it we seen we saw the move
Bishop uh E4 to B1 by uh Sean and that
is opening up the possibility of Knight
E4 uh to that square on D6 looks very
nice very very tempting and as was
mentioned any C5 we're ready to meet C5
with the advanced D5 let's see how the
game uh evolved Queen drop back to d8 so
that if I do play C5 and D5 Knight takes
will not come with a Tempo okay let's
open things up uh another idea behind
the move Bishop E1 is I want to play H5
and then put a battery so Checkmate on
H7 H4 C5 and we black has to do
something right because this H4 is
really serious threat but this is where
I was I I kind of uh was just a little
bit curious D5 now you've got to take
because if you allow me to capture and
capture you're you're you're dead now I
understand night takes night takes night
takes that's clear but I just wanted to
see uh what your reaction might be to e
uh E6 so I have to be looking at D4
right for sure no question about it D4
and here I pause for just a second
because maybe it's just one of those
circumstances I don't have a good Square
for my queen because I've got E7 in my
pocket right and I I'm looking at this
diagonal and I'm just like H uh how do I
get my queen where do I where do I put
my queen Kate help me F4 or yeah but F4
you take on and I wanted to play Queen
takes C6 check that was that was the
idea of E6 Queen takes E6 check and the
bishop would you cannot have everything
Yer why not
there's Bishop on A6 I know that that
that that's the square I would like to
uh leave my my queen so that I could
cover E6 keep E7 take on D7 but I guess
I I I just don't have that this is the
current
situation
um and uh let's refresh where the two
Sams yeah the two Sams are sharing uh
three points are sharing third place I
believe yeah with 50% uh a victory by
either player catapults them right up uh
the scoreboard there at plus one uh
provided Fabby doesn't win any more
games you know plus one starts to to be
in the mix uh Christian is there a way
for uh White to get in D5 and E6
unfortunately not no no it's just not
there and that's why you've seen the
last few moves especially the last move
for black this move Queen to f f8
because once again you go C5 I go D5 you
take I take with the Knight and that
attacks your queen on E7 right you don't
want this because after this the night
jumps in maybe I have enough time to go
E6 as well of course you're not going to
take on where did that go from that's a
mous that no but you didn't touch
anything it was like your magnetism you
just drew that Queen right to E5 sure
we'll go with that we'll go with that
the AI are whoa something is at okay
okay okay I'm not really sure let's see
with the power of my mind I'm going to
switch things around all right there we
go C5 well for you D5 with a queen on f8
this is completely different because now
if you take take I can take on E5
correct you don't attack my queen on E7
I have time for these type of tactics
you take on E5 I take on D5 I feel good
about my position true I'm a pawn up I
have the two Bishops there's no attack
on the king side so I'm feeling very
good as black right C5 this is the
position and I'm a bit surprised that
Sam is thinking because look the last
few moves I've been getting ready for
this I I've been signaling my plan to go
C5 move Queen to f8 to d8 Queen to f8 we
were discussing these type of ideas for
white as well try to open things up on
the king side but I just think that
white black is a little bit uh faster
mhm and this position for example if you
go H5 which is the the desirable move
I'm not going to go G5 because now I'm
not in time right and the Queen on f8 is
in fact liability because it's stops me
from running with the king queen to H7
and playing Knight f8 as well right and
perhaps this is what he wants H5 but now
I'm going to take on D4 I have to
recapture Knight takes Knight takes D4
Knight takes D4 now Knight takes E5 if
you take I take on D4 be
careful there's some tactics in the
position right you don't don't have
enough pieces you don't have enough
resources so can I try to improve on
that idea and start with um Queen F4 no
before H5 Rook cd1 was played okay so we
do have a move right now the question is
okay what if ah okay so the recapture
with a rook he wants to take back with a
rook and again H5 is on White's agenda
but now okay H5 let's go no more Queen
E4 though oh no more that's why I play
Knight C5 now I can go G5 oh that makes
no more Queen E4 this is a huge
difference right because you still have
to lose a lot of tempies to set up this
battery no this one is looking good I
have to say I'm looking at the position
more and more I'm starting to like black
in this one Sam Shanklin with a good
position has a good opportunity in this
one to get to plus one which would be by
the way a very very decent score we've
been watching Sam's games and uh you
know we've been poking a little bit of
fun about him getting into this rook and
and ings but right now a very complex
middle game and he seems to be handling
it very very well and by the way on time
Sam is not looking good Sam Sean is not
looking 15 minutes for Sam and 49 close
to 50 minutes for um Sam
shacklin thank you Christian as we are
going to take a break in
anticipation of the time troubles that
are going to come up in the meanwhile a
special message uh from our board of
directors and we will see you on the
other the side of the
[Music]
break
yeah um it's amazing what the club has
done for chess in general because I mean
it's already been 15 years and they've
done countless uh national championships
tournaments for juniors helping around
schools and they've just grown the game
so much across the United States I think
if I look at my own career and I look at
American chest in general we're in a
much better place than we were 15 years
ago and so the contributions have been
immense and of course it's all thanks to
Dr Jun singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that St Lou CH
Club is like a rock in the ocean of
Chess and we know that it's it's there
it is there it will be there I think
it's sense a hope that the the game of
chess will always stay Float by the mere
fact of of its existence I think it it
it sends positive waves across the
globe the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States we bring the educational benefits
of Chess to thousands of students across
the St Louis area we also promote Chess
at the highest levels hosting all levels
of the US championships as well as
high-profile tournaments that attract
the world's best players become a member
and enjoy perks such as free classes and
lectures weekly tournaments and so much
more visit St Louis chess club.org to
claim your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit World Chess h.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
verua niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Karen sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St less club.org
[Music]
education St Louis the chess capital of
the United States boasts the worldclass
St Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall of Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chess
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy hello everyone and welcome back to
our coverage of the 2023 national
championships we're in studio with Jana
Thomas Jana welcome to the show
you I know you've been working with Kate
but you have been going into the schools
for the last six years and now you're a
coordinator with school program tell us
about all the work that you do for the
club and for the schools and the kids
okay well now as a coordinator my job is
to go out to these many districts and
work with the principls and the teachers
to get these programs started so
children can learn and practice chess
exactly yeah yeah so s St Louis chess
club mission is deeply rooted in
educating about a
uh game of chess what do you like the
most about teaching chess well I love
how it relates to life so I mean I've
been in education over 20 years sh don't
tell any but I I just loved how I could
relate life lessons to the chessboard
and it really made it relatable for
children and you know they seem to catch
on a lot faster when when the lessons
are meaningful right you know yeah so I
really enjoy that and I know of course
uh besides just going um out during
school hours and stuff like that you
guys have actually been coordinating uh
also for summer school camps and you had
I know like every week during summer
there is a camp one week we had over 100
Kids signed up I would do a face plan I
had to take care of 100 Kids huge huge
teamwork here you know working with the
grand Masters and our other instructors
yeah it was a huge undertaking but it
was great we served so many children I
mean how much feedback do you get from
parents about these camps how do kids
love it well in the summer camp time you
know we had children and parents telling
us that their child told them this was
the best week of my life wow wow that's
really really nice as we see some of uh
the b-rolls from uh chess camps uh that
have taken place at the chess club can
you fit 100 kids in the St Louis just
Club I mean that's hard right that's a
lot of kids yeah not right now we can't
but soon soon we will be able to oh my
good I remember some of the parents
telling me that they drop off kids at
8:00 a.m. uh for the uh for the camp
they pick them up around 400 p.m. and
once the kids get back uh get back to
home they play chess they try to play
against their parents against siblings
and parents were like what is happening
here right exactly um Community day that
was a big Outreach and I think for a lot
of the grand Masters they really enjoy
going out and seeing the kids' faces the
kids faces light they light up like
light bulb what what give give us the
kids reaction what do they think when
they when they have a Katrina come into
the classroom and they see a Grandmaster
well they are so excited they you know
when I walked in with them they're like
oh can we have your autograph I said you
know I'm not a grandmas but I'll give
you my autograph it might be something
one day but they're so excited they're
asking for autographs and they are
actually in certain instances able to
see a reflection C of themselves like
when we have a woman grandm that's
13 oh you know children are like it's
possible it's possible when we have of
course you're talking about exactly when
we have a the youngest International
Master 14 children are like wow that's
crazy maybe you know maybe I can do this
one day because these are people who
have reached the goal that maybe they
Aspire exactly and they get to ask them
questions right so they were super super
excited it was special is there like a
school league where the other schools
compete against each other the kids want
to be on the team to plays against the
other schools yes so I mean with their
schools they they play with their
schools Scholastics puts on monthly
tournaments so our students in our
programs get to come out and then take
their chess to the next level and
compete wonderful how many coaches are
going out in the schools hm now that's a
hard number to because we I know it's a
big number it's always going everywhere
adding seasonality is a big deal too it
is but it's well above two dozen abely
yeah well above 2000 and jna you used to
be a coach now you are a coordinator the
school year is starting what can kids be
looking forward in this new school year
oh well you know lots of programming our
tournaments that's something that's huge
we are definitely trying to push for
more and more of the students that we
have in our programs to come out to our
monthly tournaments um and then we also
team up with certain districts and have
special tournaments so yeah we're just
trying to get them more involved Jenna
thank you so much for coming on and And
discussing with our audience what you've
been doing and what the St Louis chess
club is doing thank you for everything
you do for the community thank you
absolutely and let's take a look at our
standings uh we'll uh take it uh with
the ladies yes we have Karissa and beg
janova leaders of the women's tournament
with Five Points out of six just
incredible performance so far Ira crash
third place with four points and then
two-way tie for the four Place Alice Lee
and Anna zatonski with three and a half
points no result so far but in the open
section we do have one result um we have
one draw between lenier Dominguez and
leevon aronian which brought lenier
Dominguez to to tie for fourth place I
believe but we have Fabiano Karana who
is still leading and H stean who is
fourth actually pardon me Lenard just
tied with uh Hans nean to tie for second
place right with Hans still to play and
trying uh to get a point in that game
and Christian uh take it away uh where
you have the game of Hans in front of
you what's going on a lot of things have
changed since the last time we saw it I
think we left it off after the move
Bishop to B3 and we were still debating
are you going to take on A4 and change
the whole uh structure of this position
or not and he did decide to take on A4
in the end take a look at this take take
Bishop to A3 not taking back on A4 we
were discussing white has a lot of
options you can recapture but at some
point you're going to get to that pawn
anyway you might as well try to create
something in the meantime first on the
king side because that's going to be
your most difficult task in the position
to weaken Black's position on the king
side so that's what Hans is trying to do
as fast as possible with this move Queen
to H5 now if you do go G6 for example
after queen queen to H5 and
unfortunately we cannot make those moves
I believe we do did lose connection oo
if you do go G6 the problem is you
weaken all the dark squares around your
position right now so he decided to go
H6 Queen to G6 and that creates an
immediate threat Rook takes H6 because
of the pin you have a couple of options
once again as black you can get out of
this pin with a move King to h8 or you
can do what black did what Andrew Tang
did in this position Rook to D7 and I
really like this move Rook to D7 because
after a rook takes
H6 I'm looking at my time I have 10
minutes left on the clock do I want to
exchange the Queens yes I do at the
expense of a pawn sure why not because
now the situation is much more clear and
I'm able uh to understand whether I can
fend off your attack on the queen side
there's on the king side excuse me
there's no more Queens on the board so
my king is safe I'm not getting
checkmated anytime soon and I still
don't see a good way for you to open
things up on the king side I understand
you can go G4 and I'm not going to take
on G4 no that will help you because you
go F5 right that's winning but I'm going
to go G6 and that's why we see this last
move Rook D to d8 not only for the
simple fact that once you move this
bishop I want to defend my Pawn on A4
with Bishop to D7 but also in case
things open up on on the G file I'm
ready to go Rook to G8 I'm ready to
exchange as many pairs of Rooks well
hopefully all the pairs of Rooks in the
position if I manage to get Bishop of
opposite color end game without the
Rooks then I'm safe right but it's not
going to be easy to get there so still
some pressure from Hans at the same time
with every single move with every single
exchange Andrew is getting closer and
closer to establishing equality at the
same time Hans still with a pressure in
the position and on the clock I am
reminded of the game between Mishra and
lanir where uh Mishra ended up defending
two pawns down a bishops of opposite
color ending with an easy easy draw I
love this move Rook on D7 to d8 because
keep in mind black is not a pawn down he
did drop his H6 Pawn but he also won a
Pawn on the queen side with B5 takes A4
so it's actually materials even and
maybe on a good day as as uh as black
Bishop to D7 defends the pawn and again
on a very good day I can imagine my Rook
sneaking into the position and uh well I
do have a passer as well so I even
though the engine is saying white has
the pressure uh unless you do something
very concrete the next five let's try
some concrete stuff right let's go G4
what okay and I loved your move G6 by
the way all right let's go H4 right I I
I need to do something yes uh absolutely
and I kind of liked what you were saying
there about you know trading Rooks now
H5 and let's trade some Rooks okay so
that's how you want to yeah you know
like if you open up the H file for me
takes takes you know my Rook is already
there I'm I'm in business you're feeling
go the ball the position yes well good
is strong but I'm in business I mean I'm
trying to I'm trying to get a a position
I mean a real ideal position would be
this position for black because here I
feel the white pawns aren't going
anywhere Bishop E4 yeah I got the you're
getting your own I got the light squares
under control so uh again how does white
increase the pressur not and that's why
he dd8 because he wants both of the
Rooks on that King side ready to M this
G4 H4 H5 right there I start with H4 yes
sure for sure let's do the same thing G
should I play G6 yeah I like G6 and if I
now go H5 I'll take it and if you take
it I'm I'm gonna I'm GNA try to trade
Rooks on you uh just uh warning you go
Rook G5 I'll bring the other Rook over
to the G file and uh again I feel that b
structure is better but maybe black is
still it it's better for white I'm not
going to argue that point I'm just
simply saying I can imagine fortresses
easy fortresses uh with uh the Bishops
of oppos and black has its own white
excuse me has its own ideas in the
position for example if you do go Rook
takes h8 let's take it from here right
sure Rook takes h8 Rook takes h8 and now
I go Bishop to let's say C5 what do you
do next I I like my Pawn on A4 I'm
holding it so that was my plan now I go
C4 wow wow okay if you take I go D5 then
I'm happy right because I get D6
next um if you go C6 then I can take on
just a second I it's a lot of Pawns I
get it I understand it is a how do you
say it you know I understand why you
might be happy but I just it is a lot of
Pawns and maybe I can try to get some
more let's go
G4 okay now you've lost control I
know I'm losing my mind a little bit
here now we have call Rook
H4 Rook H4 King F2 look I'm trying I'm
King
F2 wow all right C3 let's go I like your
at it let's go let's go C3 let's go all
right all right yeah we're uh you guys
are getting excited oh we're getting
excited the pon is almost yeah we're
just one one square away from Coronation
that is for sure okay what if I do try
to stop that pawn with C1 I didn't
really want to play that move but okay
C2 let's go okay I'm not going to take
on C2 I understand what you want let me
I understand what you want now I take on
F5 take on F5 let's go well no I mean uh
King E3 I I I I I snuck a Pawn off
before Oh I'm I'm really happy
here I think so just a second I've got
to Rook F1 you might no I do you think
you might actually be like Rook F1 you
like Rook F because I've also got Rook
F6 and C6 okay Rook F1 I go Rook take C2
then I'm happy also yeah I just have to
be careful that The Rook doesn't come
around and give me some nasty that's
that's the only thing I have in mind
activating this King and this King on e4
is actually pretty strong I like
Christian's idea but I still feel there
are a lot of Pawns okay don't be a turn
coat you got to you got to support me on
this one yeah Rook of six right well
Rook F6 or Rook F1 because I was gonna
go here check just to see where where is
that white king living not going to F5
uh let's go to D4 to D4 I don't know why
but let's go check King
E5 and check okay just kind of just just
just test the water you're telling me
that I can go all the way to
F6 yeah I'm still not going to have much
I'm I'm just kind of okay I go to F6
check and F6 check pardon me I have some
very funny
ideas one Bishop F2 whoa I Bishop F2 is
interesting one idea I had was to meet
Rook to G5 and if I because you were
telling me if I could trade the Rooks
I'm happy Bishop F2 well that's not the
checkmating setups that you
wanted okay let's go D6 a I got my trick
in I got my trick in yes baby oh no I
got my trick in did I fall for it that
was the only thing I'm threatening chck
that's a
problem I'm threatening A1 equals Queen
check that's the check is a
problem okay okay okay what if I uh D7 I
Bishop takes D7 and then I
don't wow okay let's uh just go around
the horn a little little bit and jump
into the lady
section uh let start with the leaders
what's happening yes exactly I always
like to start with the leaders uh pay
our respects uh to beon in this case uh
when we left it we had just seen the
move G4 Knight G7 and that was
quite uh a spectacular moment Knight G7
H4 and queen d8 this is exactly where we
left it let's pick up takes takes Queen
E2 Rook
E8 do you have do you have an
understanding of this position because
this is absolute surpris chaos going on
over here Queen E3 so beum is going
directly for the weak Pawn that uh she
played H4 and
HG and okay there is a a nice Square in
the middle of the board an anchor Square
for the Knight Bishop takes Pawn takes
Queen
E4 wow a lot of weak squares in the
position some real sisy going on here
Queen D5 takes takes but at the end of
the day G5 is hanging and look at this
that's a free Pawn that's a gorgeous
pawn and and then Knight on B3 is going
to jump to C5 that feels like well it's
just positionally winning if I can get a
knight C5 and B3 it's a dream yeah this
is a giant Advantage for white
absolutely what's happening in the
Carissa game oh
there's a king on d uh oh that Bishop on
H3 uh Talia didn't get out of the
opening she just didn't when we left it
we had seen Rook B8 we were looking at
A3 but this move Bishop D2 is even
stronger not only does it pardon me not
only does it defend the Knight it
attacks the bishop Bishop to D2 Queen B5
o uh boy Carissa she looks like she's
just playing a boss game yeah wow yeah
she's dominating Queen takes G7 King
D7 oh oh no this is you're not running
away this is play on one goal the
advantage two pawns and the compensation
and the compensation Rook takes D5 check
thanks to this this uh C4 is coming F5
is coming how do you want me to open
your king up no is my question to you no
C4 F5 if I'm the trainer I'm throwing in
the towel like I don't want to I don't
want my fighter taking any more shots
here this is really overwhelming huge
advantage and again Arena these two
ladies are really neck and neck I mean
what can separate them right well gee
and if I'm in Arena shoes I'm saying
will somebody
please you know slow them down because
I'm having trouble when when Arena has
to worry about her own game right now
though ashita is on the offense right
now Queen G7 pushing the pawns E4 is on
her agenda Knight B5 we talked about
Knight G5 and uh some some ideas of uh
getting taking advantage of the H3
Square C5
E4 oh boy I said black is threatening E3
to begin that's a very very strong Fork
yes uh very potent also keep in mind
that the the pardon me the Knight on B5
requires protection right so any
captures and captures on
E2 um could leave the night over here
and Ina has only 12 minutes on the clock
and she still needs to make 17
moves not liking what I'm seeing here
guys that's a very difficult position
for her wow okay let let let's be uh
concrete and let's just see some forcing
moves for a moment if I play the move C5
C6 which has the benefit at least of um
stopping Bishop takes B5 in lots of
variations how would it Go Kate uh do
you just move the bishop to C8 you don't
include any captures right I don't feel
like I want to okay because I want to
Target that D Pawn in the future okay
fair and uh I do recognize that E3 is
coming so what do I have to do
to the I I was about to play Knight C4
but taking on F3 I I don't like that so
let me deep
breath G5 F4 hitting G5 the Knight on G5
I'm I'm dreaming of Knight C4 okay I'm
gonna play E3 okay fair let me take your
knight I'll take back with a pawn with
the pawn Fair okay Bishop we got to take
rook and Knight C4
finally um at the end of the day I must
say I even you know you just you went
with the flow you didn't do anything uh
even this position still feels like uh
ashria might might be doing well because
I can put the Rook back to E7 yes and I
can even try to double the Rooks or
Knight C5 Knight E4 I do not feel good
about taking this Pawn um and I'm a pawn
Grabber but uh what am I supposed to do
here here uh Bishop
Bishop um you know it's for scami I know
I've got a prep for it actually you have
to get ready for it yeah maybe this Rook
has to go um this is not an easy one for
arena and again ashria who's been you
know Father Christmas in the tournament
she's just been giving presents to
everybody Arena says where's my present
why aren't you being uh friendly to me
uh this is a this is a tough one what's
caught your eye uh Christian well I'm
still you're still uh looking at the
tell you um it actually gets me a little
bit depressed because especially the
last move take a look at this King to E8
such a sad move to uh make you have to
get off this diagonal I understand that
because the Rook takes D5 was coming in
the position but to put your Rooks on h8
first of all the Rook is still on h8
hasn't moved since the beginning of the
game and now the other Rook is on that
side as as well it looks some like some
sort of Chess 960 position right in
which you unfortunately weren't able to
get your pieces out I have a buffet of
options right now I can open you up with
F5 do I want to give you the G5 Pawn
probably not because I don't want to
calculate I'm lazy so I'm going to go C4
I'm going to open you this way and take
a look if you do take take my Bishop as
well yes take it take it take it Queen
d8 I don't think so so that's a
Checkmate on the board that's game over
so I mean this is such a difficult
situation I have to say I'm looking at
the position I'm not seeing nothing
Talia getting back into the game in this
one also her time situation is
disastrous 2 minutes and 40 seconds for
a lot of moves around 14 moves from this
point on but it's not about that it's
about the position you're just simply
completely lost yeah uh no disputing
that one quick H check in on a pretty
important game between Alice Lee and
Anna zatonski this is one of those where
you know looks aren't that deceiving uh
I like what what Alice has done she's
positioned her Rook on B5 so that Anna's
Rook on B8 is playing a defensive role
I'm playing an offensive role and I'm
seeing B2 B4 by young Alice Lee that
Rook on B1 suddenly helping its
colleague hitting the clearly suggests
what Al wants to do in the next move and
just looking at Anna that's a a typical
pose where she's totally fixed she she
knows that she's been outplayed that
she's stands worse and that B2 B4 she's
played the move H6 just to make sure
there are no back rang checkmates right
making uh lft and making a square for
her her her King and I'm expecting A4
and
you know again it's look it's still a
long long grind ahead but uh I don't
usually see Anna getting
outplayed uh certainly not by Alice has
a really clear plan she just wants to
open the B5 push A5 get that extra pawn
and the black Rooks are just so passive
on the back rank exactly so we'll keep
an eye on that one I want to go to the
game of tatev for a moment because that
was when we saw Bishop takes remember
this whole Bishop takes D5 and I was
asking who won out of that deal where
the there was a a bishop on C8 a knight
on B8 and suddenly the black pieces
really took uh dominent positions King
H7 and we're catching up with the
players all right well now
things kind of well opened up and just
feels like black recovered from any
potential issues that there were
in the opening but is G4 not an
issue unless to Target well there is
that King on on
H7 I almost feel like I should go back
with my sorry I almost feel like I
should go back with my king uh because
this the this threat of G4 is really
looking a little bit frightening unless
I can I play G4 may I ask question
you may ask so if I go Knight
H4 I assume to capture going yes that
was uh
my
uh well I kind of like white here a bit
the still a lot of play in the position
Christian where's the action in the Sean
well in the two Sams uh game yes Sam
savian versus Sam Shanklin because we
simplified the position quite a lot
right I think we left somewhere around
here there were still a lot of uh pieces
on the board we're saying that after
Knight to
C5 H5 G5 and the big difference is that
you cannot get your queen on the B1 H7
diagonal so what do you have to do
simplify the position pull the brakes as
white because you're in trouble now you
realize you're in trouble the two
Bishops are getting activated in the
position to exchange everything exactly
Knight to H2 and that's exactly the
point he wants to transfer this Knight
to a more stable position on G4 not only
that you're defending the pawn on E5
from G4 but you're also attacking the
pawn on H6 okay Queen E7 G3 Queen to D7
and we have at this position right now
and very nicely timed by Sam with this
move F6 because you give me one more
move I'm going to go Knight to G4 and at
least I'm exchanging some pieces once
you play that move F6 so he says no no
no I'm not giving you enough time to do
that I'm going to go F6 now if you take
I take with the Knight you have problems
with a Pawn on H5 you have to defend it
with a bishop Pawn G6 but right now
again you're very unstable your Knights
are very unstable we know that the
knights need outposts they don't have
any outposts right now one of them is on
C3 sure you can call that an outpost but
I'm going to kick it away with B5 B4
make space for my Bishops to get
activated Knight D5 on your corns on
both sides of the board definitely favor
black you don't have Knight to E4
because I take and then the pawn on B2
is hanging as well there's a lot of
problems you have to solve and this one
is not looking good at the same time the
material is limited so if I do manage to
exchange some pieces maybe I will have
decent chances to make a draw F6 Knight
to G4 is also an idea in the position
and after take F5 not taking on E5 if
you take take take I have the pawn and
the compensation as we already kind of
understood mhm and uh if you don't then
you have to go F5 right in in the
current position after F6 if I can ask
F4
F5
mhm King F7 oh you okay I thought I was
doing myself a solid by just trading off
the pawns you can you can trade off the
pawns but you're still losing some I
I've activated your king in the
meanwhile too that's the problem take a
look at this and how sad this position
is the pair of Bishops are just so
strong only if you could take these
pawns off the off the board right then
it could be an easy draw you're not
getting there not even and once you go
B3 then my king invades easy March this
is not looking good for Sam and by the
way Sam is in trouble in terms of uh his
time situation as well only 5 minutes on
the clock he took on F6 and played the
move Bishop to G6 the most resilient
defense in the position
uh did uh White takes on F6 Knight takes
F6 Bishop G6 yes and I liked what you
said which was uh boot this Knight out
of Dodge play B5 B4 then bring your
knight to D5 open up the position for
your bishop and just enjoy the fact that
you have much more harmonious play what
the Knight on H2 is making pretty sad
impression so Shanklin it's a a
torturous situation for Sam Sean couple
games BS on the queen side will just
start running B5 B4 exactly uh a couple
games we want to really catch up on
first of all let's do our our tournament
leader a favor let's jump into the game
of Ray Robson and Fabby uh when we left
it we had just
seen you know it's funny you had
mentioned Queen B3 uh you're GNA have to
whisper from that one because Ray Ray
played your move Queen B3 uh Kate and
I'm not sure that I'm a fan of what Fabi
did he played D5 okay so let's go back a
few
moves and we're we're right here and I'm
looking at this bishop this light Square
bishop and I'm saying this guy's kind of
a happy camper right it's it's a it's a
nice bishop and it's got a a lot of uh
diagonals from which it and then if we
catch up sudden suddenly all the bishop
all of its Avenues have been closed off
it's not a happy camper anymore not so
happy and uh who benefited by all of
these Pawn pushes uh I'm not convinced
that Fabby improve this position maybe I
mean I understand he wants to push for
A3 and then Fab is happy that the pawns
on C3 and D4 they're blocked so he can
attack them with the bishop or even
Knight B6 Knight
A4 okay um the clear some cobwebs when
the Ray Robson versus fobby did all of
these Advanced pawns uh help fabby's
calls it's still balanced um Still Still
balanced King F7 on the board maybe
slightly more pleasant for black just
for the simple fact that I can always
try transfer my Rook on the B file Rook
A7 Rook B7 and at some point I can
dictate the fact that we're going to
exchange the A4 Pawn for the B2 Pawn the
question is is is it enough right for
any sort of an advantage King to E2 was
played I'm looking at the position I
understand there's some tension maybe
that slightly favors black but I don't
see much uh much else than that so I'm
saying this is more or less balanced I
don't see a good way to improve the
position for either side I think this
one is going to end in a draw well I
I'll be the devil's advocate in
favs you're saying that white might
actually be better yeah okay give give
give me but what if I okay well that you
really want to be better okay uh that is
a question uh if I'm playing for a win I
have to play B3 right yeah H B3 point
right yes because if I trade we
understand we're going to make a draw
takes Bishop takes B3 I was trying to
bring my King Pawn on A3 right now is so
well defended right yeah I was trying to
bring my king to C2 it's not that I was
trying to win the pawn on A3 so much as
just control it right you know okay if
we go back to the current position uh
Christian what I would like to do is
white like you've just played King F7
I've just played King E2 like if you
could just make a move Rook A6 sure
transfer to Rook on F1 okay Knight F1 I
will go Rook B Rook
a if you like go ahead Rook a rook Rook
B6 uh either Bishop C1 or Rook A2 I'm
not really too sure Bishop C1 let's say
so here what I'm trying to do to go back
is yeah I was trying to put my knight on
the E3 Square so that when you play A3
now if you don't mind play A3 B3 and
suddenly Tada you have some pressure on
my pawns exactly exactly that was take
take this D5 Pawn is under pressure the
knight from D2 was passive the Knight on
E3 uh gives me more even then it's very
difficult to prove something agree agree
but what if black is not playing with
The Rook back and forth but maybe
transfers his Knight like I can go he
play Knight by the way yeah Knight B6
because I can be thinking about bringing
the Knight to A4 potentially or even if
you move back with your Bishop to C1 I
can go C8 E6 he did play Knight B6 so I
think he's channeling your ideas as well
Kina so so just to be clear Knight to F1
where is that Knight going you're going
to go A3 A4 A3 so here I have to take
you have to take yeah I'm not going to I
don't want to see the Knight come to C C
and I have a feeling that's probably how
this position is going to get resolved
check and Bishop C4 this would be
problems terrible for white for White
Knight to B6 Knight F1 A3 at some point
you have to do this exactly then we're
just exchanging everything by the way
Knight to F1 is on the board exactly
these guys are good these guys are very
these guys are good uh time is a factor
whenever I I Ray Robson I it always
seems to me that regardless of the
position Ray has less time yeah he has
10 minutes only and Fabby has 22 minutes
and by the way we saw this is move 31
already so this is a
luxury and Karissa is about to win again
Fabby is great at grinding down the time
trouble players Dar rouche we saw
earlier in the tournament he did that
Karissa well we knew Karissa was just uh
she had just such a fabulous position
against Talia let's stay with that one
just because I have a feeling I I think
we will it's inevitable by the way uh
gissa said yeah I love F5 let me uh
sacrifice a pawn and I'm just your your
your King's just uh Frozen in the center
and open Highway on the defile Rook F7
to defend Queen H5 pinning death Rook
threatening Queen takes as well as Rook
takes D7 King f oh we're about to see
Queen takes
F7 she did not play it surprisingly so I
what I understand she's improving her
Bishop F1 you know there's no rush I
mean queen F7 does finish the game on
the spot bishop and now we going to play
Bishop C4 okay she's trying to get away
the only check in the position with
Queen to E3 that's uh yeah if you if you
bring your King well King G8 Bishop C4
it's King G8 Bishop C4 and if King E8
then Bishop B5 and another pin wow I
King by the way King G8 I can also take
on D7 right now I suspect so just to be
more forceful Bishop C4 is is nice but
uh forceful I appreciate as well I mean
I think Talia is just going she's
waiting to see Bishop C4 she'll have
seen enough after this move Bishop C4
because again the king oh this is a game
that you know Talia never got out of the
opening no and I think that combination
of A6 and Bishop D7 really uh U messed
her up her her scheme of development uh
was poor no and Karissa just handled the
position better Bishop you see Bishop C4
and for Carissa I must say I
mean just flowing beautifully I mean
just you know plus four coming into now
she's going to be plus in this game she
didn't have to make any difficult
Decisions by the way she got a very nice
Advantage then she just developed her
pieces and game was over absolutely so
we are expecting a handshake very very
shortly and this is her road ahead
Carissa so right now she's facing Talia
Cervantes and we are expecting her to
win and then atusa pishan and Nazi pizza
and again all these ladies are
struggling so far in the tournament
exactly so she's playing because she's
played against her nears right as you
pointed out uh Christian she's already
Knight f8 Rook d8 Talia is like oh my
gosh what a position for poor Talia this
has been a nightmarish tournament her
winning positions as we saw yesterday
against tatev she's let them slip and
absolutely very difficult tournament
especially last year she finished third
she was actually fighting even to try to
win that tournament uh this year is
different but that's it's difficult just
difficult to play the best players in
the United States absolutely and by the
also maintaining the pace everything is
is turning out roses for her as well
just just look at this this is just like
a dream position for bean first of all
she's a pawn to the good but look at the
Knights Knight is hitting C5 the Knight
on G5 is hitting E6 The Rook has the
open file so it's about to play Rook to
H6 she's a big favorite to win another
Pawn Yeah and I going be trying to trap
that Knight on C4 because if you go
Knight D2 then I'm just Rook D1 and
you're going to lose another Pawn when
yeah or even F3 I was about to say you
wanted to trap the Knight I thought you
were going I thought you were hunting
bigger game than just a pawn with F2 F3
and yeah this is this is terrible Nasi
uh again uh a poor opening and beum had
a big Advantage coming right out of this
opening and she's played it really well
uh to to establish a winning position
again I'm just going to check in on
Arena crush's game because Arena came
into today's round uh hoping that
her her rivals in first place would not
win their games and at the same time
thinking she's playing against ashria
who has done very poorly in the
tournament up to now and we are up to
dat Bishop C4 wow what do you think of
this I mean it it just it seems so scary
I'm a little surprised that the pawns
got traded because I kind of liked the
white Pawn on D5 exactly for this reason
for the bishop on C4 not being that
active you you you had prescribed Bishop
C8 and leaving the pawn on the board it
was aa's decision was to trade and well
I mean she does have a passer herself
right or potentially yeah it's
definitely a choice uh but e takes F3
isn't that
somehow surprising or wow can we go like
Knight takes F3 and queen G4 something
direct well yeah I I was thinking wait a
minute I mean you know you're almost
thinking that the king might get you
know trapped but sorry go ahead uh crush
me Queen G4 check I'm going back do you
have a kill it
might I'm looking at Queen H3 I'm not a
happy camper here no uh Christian well
since this one still has a lot of
minutes left
to yes there's only a few seconds left
for Andrew so maybe we can switch that
one for the last couple of moves before
the first time control and then we can
move back to this one Bobby by the way
has traded H nean versus Andrew Tang
yes Andrew just played with eight
seconds on his clock this last move
Bishop to C4 there's two moves before
the time control King to H4 which has
been played so he has to play them fast
whatever he does he has to play them
fast now King H4 doesn't come with the
threat of King takes H5 there'll be Rook
h8 but it just asked the question what
do you do make a move make a move please
make a move yes okay uh with no time on
my clock I'm quickly playing Bishop E2
correct yes you can play that yeah
Bishop to E2 again we discuss that you
don't actually have to defend that I'm
kind of scared about well once he go
Bishop D6 10 seconds 10 seconds he has
to make a move Bishop B5 Bishop Bishop
B2 B2 okay we sort of uh expected that
move it does defend the pawn on H5 but
uh Hans is enjoying the position I mean
it's how much do you enjoy this position
you go Bishop D6 I go King G6 you have
to drop back you cannot take that pawn
that's the problem because then my own
Pawn runs down the board so it's one of
those things I I would love you to play
King E6 so I could play G6 and I would
love for you to play King G6 so I could
play E6 but your king is actually just
waiting staying there yeah and I'm just
staying there and what you're doing is
you're just moving to and fro with the
bishop so even the visually it looks
like white is absolutely uh dominating
dominating how do I break through so
what if I go to pick out the pawn on A4
Rook
B7 Rook B7 okay sorry I I I'm going to
let you but I'm not going to play the
move Bishop B5 I'll just let you why
don't you play the move Bishop B5 uh I
want her to bring her Rook back ah you
actually want that okay okay but if I go
now Bishop E6 bishop6 E6 D6 pardon now I
go back or well now I King and I'm
hoping for A3 right don't you have to go
back with your Bishop yeah but I go to
C5 okay I have to go
back I want to go Rook B4 but then you
want to just play Bishop B5 right I have
nothing then I'll close the door on your
on your um at some point you have to
sacrifice you have to go E6 all right
let's go in that position why not let's
just in this position all the way
towards the end even though that's
probably the worst position I have right
now because I want my Rook active but
let's say Rook B before B B5 now I go E6
in this position sure wow okay and you
take H5
yeah okay just a second I just have to
make sure that you're not checkmated
right um
I hope I'm not yeah exactly check go up
okay my Rook on B4 is really terrible
really terrible I'm not going to lie
that's the worst okay let's let's keep
the Rook on the seventh round on the
seven Rook A7 so the current position
sorry I'm going to just refresh my board
and once again what are the times of the
two players uh Kate so H has 30 minutes
and Andrew is on 30 second increment 30
minutes I thought it was 3 minutes to 30
seconds I miss I misread the clock the
last move this is move 40 so once Hans
makes it 34 seconds for Andrew to
complete his first time control so what
you're saying is the way you want to win
the game is you want to have your Pawn
on
E6 so you're going to make a move and as
soon as the bishop moves back you want
your Pawn on E6 and then your King on G6
right right that's the only way I see to
make your uh approach okay you go back
right King
F7 well King
F7 if you go G6 I go King F6 I'm just
worried about getting
checkmated happy I captured the pawn on
H5 but now the king doesn't feel so safe
there you're channeling my fears exactly
I was just uh afraid of getting
checkmated I didn't know if uh the idea
was to do something of this nature very
doubtful I mean it is an AC of King but
but the bishop on D3 is defending that
pawn on F5 and and where do I want to
play and uh we're just going to take a
break from our analysis because one
Karissa Yip is on fire and she's in
studio Carissa congratulations another
game another Victory and in what fashion
uh this victory was just uh very very
dominant in an explosive game take us
through the critical moment it felt like
by the way you almost got a winning
position out of the opening did you feel
the same
way yeah so um I know Italia played
Bishop D7 in round one I think um and I
briefly checked it and it just didn't
look very good because white can sort of
transposed to a an English attack like a
really good English
attack um but it just felt like she
wasn't quite sure what to do against
this setup um it's just like kind of
awkward for black if you know she plays
E5 and Bishop E6 so she just kind of
like wasted a Tempo yeah um with Bishop
D7 yeah but I think this like Knight
takes D4 plan wasn't good and after that
she was trying to oh after Bishop C6 the
engine was saying close to plus three
Advantage for you it it was absolutely
uh crazy the evaluation yeah I didn't I
didn't realize um
yeah I don't know maybe I just can't
evaluate Sicilian super well or
something nobody can we didn't think
that we thought it's maybe plus one
something along those lines but not
completely uh winning and you conducted
the attack I have to say admirably
because you never let your opponent back
into the game maybe the only opportunity
she had was to try for it takes D5 just
take the piece and hope that she's not
getting checkmated what were the
variations that you are calculating
right
now yeah so I definitely felt e takes D5
was critical um so obviously I take back
and black has a choice between yeah
Bishop B5 Bishop B7 and then I think
here
um I mean I'm kind of I was debating
between like Rick E1 Queen E4 and Bishop
D2 sort of cuz I think like one plus is
that the bishop is sort of Awkward on B5
um and like once I snag this B4 on it
could easily end up trapped there mhm
mhmh because of like these sort of like
C4 ideas A4 ideas so B do stuff I felt
yeah I felt practically this was quite
good for me um and I also felt that she
wouldn't go for it just cuz you know it
looks really scary for black and I think
she also was running a bit low on time
at this point and there are still like a
lot of moves to go until move 40 yeah
this was move 15 and she only had 30
minutes on the clock definitely a lot of
decisions on the horizon for her as well
and she did play Knight to C5 but after
this you're just opening absolutely
every single Avenue towards her King and
that comes with devastating
consequences and I have to say I mean
the end position Bishop to C4 and Rook
to d8 if you move the queen Rook to G1
is a m it's such a sad position did you
feel at all bad for your opponent or
there's no such feelings in a game of
chess in a competition such as this one
I honestly thought that it was just like
really geometrically nice which is why I
played Bishop C4 instead of like Rook
takes D7 um and I think it would be like
a cute Checkmate if she played like
Queen C5 I take on f8 and then Rook G1
yes uh yeah yes no I thought this was
super nice
um I did feel a little bad cuz CU you
know tal and I are uh friends but I
think it was a nice game and usually I
try to separate those feelings a bit
because it like affects my game so yeah
well Karissa things are going uh
swimmingly for uh you up to this point
congratulations still a few games to go
but you're in a good spot to V for that
National Championship congratulations
we'll see you tomorrow thank you and uh
our congratulations ations as well and
now our attention turns to the game of
beum I mean because can she keep the
pace uh again beum and Carissa coming
into today's competition with a score of
plus four that means they've won four
games with no losses and Carissa's just
won our fifth game and it looks like
beum is putting touches as well I think
she's having an incredibly good position
and it's just winning it's res
yeah you don't have moves you actually
don't have moves King G7 I take on C7
that's that's the easi you move the
Knight your Rook is not protected so I
take on E6 right the Knight on C8 right
you don't have where to move the knight
from C7 Knight on C8 also I could take
the pawn on A7 but this I got to tell
you you look at this
position it's it's it's awful with a
capital A I mean this is just there's no
moves it's it it it's like like a susong
yeah well it's even worse it's a worst
wor seen in a long time goodness I was
just thinking if there are any chances
to like set up a stalemate you know the
pwns are blocked the king is kind of at
the edge of the board so the stalemate
you want to set up is with this Knight
this Knight would cover H7 this Knight
would cover G7 and then what you've got
to do is get rid of this guy this guy
and this guy now it's easy to get rid of
the Rooks are you g to get rid of both
Knights
yeah so yeah that's not happening no
there I I I don't see any stal it's
first of all let's say you go Knight d8
Knight Edgar eight yeah okay I don't
have to take on E7 not at all you're not
threatening to take on B7 if you take on
B7 that's corination for my Pawn
exactly oops so you're still in
a and you dropped your base it's so
interesting they whole both Karissa
by the way Knight to B6 was played now
we're expecting Knight takes E6 on the
board to
come okay I mean that we're can also
catch on a seven that's the sadistic
approach that's the my Approach I would
just take the pawn on A7 because that
means I've got a passer in the position
and we know that Knights hate a pawns
and Nazi is just looking away like oh my
goodness what have I done she knows yeah
she's she's not happy she knows that
with this loss the problem is the dreams
of even catching no these players are
gone yes her tournament for the national
championship the her dream is over
exactly and for beum uh Rook takes A7
thank you very much I will take that
pawn as well that just is
another uh Victor Kon I would say
Fang in the position this Pawn is is uh
so it's these ladies are just killing
the field uh sometimes you get in those
tournaments where it's a two-horse race
and it's like nobody can touch them it's
amazing what I'm seeing beum and uh
Carissa all by themselves and even Arena
Crush struggling to night and you know
the way they are winning the games just
I mean today overwhelming overwhelming
just outplaying their opponents
absolutely Knight C4 and their line
score
is absolutely identical right yeah
drawing the first round and draw the
fourth drawing the fourth between each
other right and wins after that exct in
the rest of the
games very very uh
Eerie situation in the lady section I
have to say and again the point that you
made as well it's a very similar pattern
of how they're winning their games this
one complete domination for both of the
players exactly
and uh Nazi tried to sacrifice a knight
hoping that you know the pawn gets to
the C file and can start running Rook
B7 that's stopping the pawn lots of luck
with the and that pawn on A6 also has a
path straight forward that one is going
yes yes the problem is you go C3 I go A7
you go C2 but now I catch a pawn Knight
B3 and then Rook takes C7 is coming just
a quick note here I agree that I can
drop back with the Knight but can I be
you play for the beauty priz you can do
whatever
you you really can do whatever you want
yes you can do Absolut as a
commentator oh oh for n you take my
queen I take on E7 you get the queen but
he get checkm on H7 exactly exactly KN
takes Rook takes and I'm the first you
get the queen but I get the
Checkmate oh my goodness uh very very
very impressive uh by the two ladies and
reminds me of the song Anything You Can
Do I Can Do Better you know you win I
win you drew I drew anything you can do
I can do better and we do have A7 on the
board will we see that variation with C3
and queen or will we see your variation
I think we're seeing a resignation I
don't think we're seeing any varations
anymore no yeah I think Nasi certainly
has seen enough this has been well just
again from the opening Dreadful yeah
yeah yeah no um and she knows it I
mean it's one of those games that just
simply don't go in your favor right and
Nazi she's a new carakan player she
hasn't faced this E5 Knight F3 these
type of positions so she's you know
learning through experience but
sometimes experience is painful
right and these are not e easy and
that's the resignation right
there wow uh our congratulations to beam
is it's again it's a two horse race and
I'm just going to check in on the game
of Arena because she's she's playing
against shra as mentioned ashria comes
into today's competition not doing that
well but ashria might be playing her
best game of the tournament right here
right now when we left it we just left
it around these parts takes takes takes
f four by the way now she's back it
seems like arena is back Arena's back
takes takes rookie one and oh but arena
is on one minute by the way keep that in
mind whoa uh by the way I I was about to
say this last move Bishop E5 set up a
potential Rook takes F2 Queen takes G3
and let's hunt the white king queen E3
and I like really nice move here for
black Rook F4
I don't want to trade Queens no you
don't and I want to bring the light
Square Bishop to maybe F5 and E4 okay
Bishop F5 Bishop E4 on your
agenda wow because I uh I don't think
you can sacrifice the queen can you I no
I don't want to do that the because you
have Rook the8 CH getting the bishop but
the move I have in mind funnily enough
as Knight D4 my knight on B5 is actually
playing no role what's soever in the
game I'm not threatening to take I'm not
threatening to take but here I might on
a good day be threatening uh Knight F3
and just you know throwing a monkey
wrench into your attacking and if I
capture the Knight with the Rook then
I've got the back rank check okay then
I've got the back rank check this is
what you were talking about and uh The
Rook uh lassos this one so um we do have
Queen E3 on the board you were about to
say Arena's down to one minute yeah one
minute against ashita's 10th
minutes and we do have a result in the
Wesley so game it looks like I see the
two kings in the middle of the board so
probably a draw yes they repeat it three
times and it's a draw okay going back
again to the arena uh what move did they
just play Move
36 33 33 excuse me Queen you know you
would like to play Queen H5 but that's
looks very dangerous because White's
Rook can just go to the H5 G she played
Queen
G7 uh sorry I I what did you just say
well if you don't go Queen G7 yes but
want to go to H file to maybe do
something you know on H3 yes it's kind
of helping white indeed it does because
I've Got The Rook Rook coming
immediately to H1 by the way we do have
some moves Queen G7 and Rook H1 on the
board
that's a bit strange King H7 King H7 but
doesn't that allow some checks Bishop D3
I'm sry I thought she might play Bishop
F4 that's what I thought as a way of
Defending or Rook F6 right or Rook F6 h
a bit King
H7 okay I'm not I'm not a fan what do
you think Kate I'm not a fan of even
Queen G7 I like The Rook F4 to kind of
keep the pieces active but I don't think
black is in any trouble because after
Bishop D3 I can develop my Bishop from
C8 um and I'm still having good position
with black pieces are you sure just a
little bit concerned that
uh you you you're putting your pieces
into positions where you're where you
could be getting pinned okay Queen G6
right and let me just play Rook H4 but
now like I'm oh unless takes F2 but
Knight C5 also is a okay that you can
capture that with no you cannot capture
with Bishop because Queen takes G3 so
Bishop E1 was it's all about the time
right now yes I'm just going to refresh
the board everybody don't be angry
Bishop to E1 okay so arena is basically
saying I have a move uh your turn I'm G
to get my my my Bishop out of uh these
ideas of of Rook takes F2 maybe on a
good day I I I but now Knight
C5 what do you know Knight C5 okay
Knight C5 maybe B before or all right so
seriously
yes I mean no respect I feel
disrespected on every level after moov
like Bishop takes sa you're right I I
don't know what came over me just now
but uh yeah this does not feel if you
take it I go Bishop G4 well I think
think you're going to play Bishop G4
almost regardless right correct yes I
play Knight C5 because I want to take
away all your naughty checks on the
light naughty on the B17 diagonal okay
if I'm going to be naughty let me uh
bring my Rook up and just ask a question
your turn what are you GNA do what's
your question okay I don't know so what
if I do go Bop G4 again okay here we go
uh do I you have something in mind but I
don't know what I was going to play
Bishop D3 check okay that's a check see
what okay so what I really want to do is
play Bishop here and I don't want to
suffer the consequences Bishop F4 so I
played Rook H4 as a Prelude to playing
Bishop D2 and Bishop G4 immediately on
the board by the way not even Knight C5
G4 first but this one has a very direct
and concrete aim uh check but there's a
problem right I mean I always have
Bishop
D5 to defend Bishop D5 to defend the the
check okay I've got to get this guy into
the game right Knight
C5 yeah Knight C5 looks nice Bishop D3
check
okay what's going on Kate in this that
looks like Bishop F5 I have to play
immediately right do we King G8 I mean
you going to give up that pawn m
as we keep an eye on this very important
game uh for the third place we have a
tournament leader in studio with you
Christian be there is absolutely no
separation between you and Karissa at
this moment head to-head you guys are
having the identical line scor you drew
the first game you drew the fourth game
against each other and won every single
game after that what do you need to
create that
separation I don't know I think we need
four more rounds for that right
absolutely or tie breaks who knows we're
going to have to wait and see tell us
about today's game this was not an easy
one you were playing a two-time national
champion how did you approach it and
when did you feel like you're starting
to slowly take
over mhm uh I felt like after the
opening I was already better because she
started thing and she started to mix up
the ideas I feel like she uh Queen C7 is
one idea Bishop G Bishop G6 and Knight
F5 is another one so she was very
undecisive so I felt like I should be
already better I felt like I'm putting
pressure and after the game we talked uh
a bit and then she said she didn't
expect E4 at all uh which was like a
nice opening choice I got lucky I guess
absolutely and it felt like you knew the
plans you knew what you had to do in the
position as you mentioned she was mixing
up a few too many ideas and it was at
this point when you started finding this
plan opening up the C file and then this
very aggressive move G4 followed by
H4 tell us your uh train of thought that
led to you making this
decision well uh the thing is that I
grew up playing E4 I'm an E4 player I
played bunch of uh kakan lines
especially E5 is my main line here so it
was good to be back because I just
pretty much I know everything every idea
in the position so I wasn't afraid of G4
uh because I know this idea exists and
it's just um usually it's better to put
Knight on G7 for me uh first of all and
secondly if you look at the position
Knight is the only good uh piece they
they have so yeah on F5 so I felt like
if I play G4 H4 my position should be
already better but I didn't know how
better it is because I wasn't sure if I
should include a include A6 or not but
usually you should include a A6 to make
a little bit like a weakness on C6 so I
felt like I was doing fine here and
perhaps that was uh one of her mistakes
as well not playing A6 herself and
blocking the position as is allowing you
to create another weakness on C6 and
then you guys got into this end game
after a few trades and you got the pawn
on G5 but still things were not that
easy because the position remains a
little bit closed at the same time you
have the C file you have that B3 in the
bag in terms of percentages how sure did
you think that you're going to win this
game I was absolutely sure I when I
played King G2 I I saw I'm check mating
and Knight C5 is coming she basically
doesn't have any moves she told me uh
for her better idea was Rook F7 she
mixed up the Moes like she played
instead of Rook
f8 Rook F7 uh yeah Rook F7 here her idea
is like Knight G5 Rook F4 if I play F3
she wants to play Knight C Knight E3 and
then Rook f8 maybe mhm mhm because if I
play Rook E1 she can play uh Knight G G4
which seem yeah which seemed like a good
idea but even here I don't know like it
feels like her Knights on G7 is a
problem to be honest yeah especially
with the pawn on G4 right so you
definitely don't want to give that pawn
and you didn't you executed all your
tasks in this position you broke through
got the pawn on A7 and finalized game
Megan congratulations uh big victory for
you a lot of games left still four
finals for you uh to create that
separation with Karissa we'll wish you
all success and we'll see you tomorrow
one quick question thank you so much
yeah one quick question for you um uh
bam uh in this position that I have on
my board I don't know if you can see it
uh for for for for me uh I'm a French
defense player I'm a caroon player and
we always as French defense players we
love the square F5 for our night so I
thought you played a really really nice
game and in fact you had too easy a time
in this game that you won uh a very
smooth Victory I thought the move H6 H5
was blacks Na's only I thought yes
absolutely I thought that's the move uh
that's the move that's why at some point
I thought maybe H5 was better for me
because uh if I take if she TS it's like
her position is collapsing basically and
no no no that's why I thought H5 is the
move instead of like taking on G5 I see
and I was thinking
uh but I here I thought I can take on G5
and I was calculating Knight a H4 Knight
H4 okay so then at least in the so she's
fighting back if you take I take on G6
and queen G4 right I'm P up yeah no I
apologize I did it the wrong way uh
sorry bam yeah I would of course take on
G5 then take on uh G6 and F4 right I
wasn't sure yet but I felt like her best
idea is to play H5 and then I'm playing
Queen uh Queen C2 F5 I feel like my
position should be better exactly I did
too I just thought that H5 was her best
chance of resisting and well whatever
you're
doing keep it up you're doing it very
very well very impressive yeah plus five
uh good luck uh for the remaining
rounds and uh yes thank you beum and uh
women's standings uh with these two
results in the books so we have the
leaders winning both of her G both of
their games so K sa and beim toir janova
with six points out of seven uh they're
running away from the rest of the people
there yeah oh no question about it and
as we go to our uh break we asked uh oh
sorry we're going to do the uh uh
standings for the open with two draws
see here we have two draws so Fabiano
Carona still leading but we have weso
and Lenard Dominguez who caught up to H
stean with four points exactly with h
still going on and as we're going to go
on break uh we caught up with the uh uh
players from the open side and ask them
about their favorite memories of the St
Louis chess club as the 15th anniversary
has been celebrated and well take a
listen the St Lou chess club is
celebrating its 15th year anniversary
tell me a little bit about its impact in
the United States and do you have any
favorite moments uh yeah it's honestly
pretty incredible it's already been 15
years it just feels like yesterday I was
here but it's I was here 10 years ago
for a tournament the impact has been
amazing for not just us chess with
juniors in the US all these camps they
do for younger players and obviously for
high rated players the US championship
and other high Lev so overall it's just
been an incredible club and I'm hoping
for more and better things to come yeah
well St Louis chess club basically
created Chef in the USU and there was
not really a career for the most part
for any players I mean they have to
travel to Europe to get exposure and my
favorite part in St Louis is playing the
ultimate moves every year and yeah it's
just a tremendous impact that players
like myself can make a good living um
playing chess it's an occasion to to
celebrate I think all of us all the
chess family really because what they
have done for chess not only in the US
but also in the world I think yeah there
are so many but uh playing Gary for
example uh I think uh it was 2017 the
first time I played uh he also played
the rabbit and blit so uh for me I mean
he was my hero from my childhood and uh
I thought I would never really play him
after he retired in 2005 well my
favorite memory was surely winning the
US championship in 2018 but you know I
played that first US championship in
2009 I've been here all 15 years you
know I'm sort of an Oldtimer now there
have been I remember my first US
Championship there's zero other
participants from that tournament that
are here now and you know that's been
the case for a while certainly the
landscape of Chess has changed a lot in
the United States uh and St Louis has
had a lot to do with it well the impact
is enormous of course I mean it's not
just in the United States but over the
world and it's the most prestigious Club
in in our world at least uh in the Chess
World everybody wants to come to St
Louis you know just to see what's
happening here and to take part in
tournaments because they're always very
nicely organized one of my favorite
memories is um
actually talking with h Fabiano and uh
Magnus when we had to play some tiebreak
and I think um why is it my favorite
because you know mostly you have um
players kind of trying to say that I'm
the winner I want to fight for it and
there we just said okay come on we fix
finish on the same points let's just uh
stand there and pose with the cup three
of us so for me it was very funny yeah
it's difficult to overstate the impact
that the chess club has had over us
chess and also to a degree over World
Chess in general but bringing chess to
such a high level to the United States
to St Louis um reaching a level of Chess
that we haven't seen since uh since like
the early part of the century when there
was so many of the best chess players in
the world from the United States we have
that again and uh for example um in 2016
we were able the US team was able to
bring back a gold from the Olympiad I
think a lot of these achievements for us
chess are really very strongly connected
to St Louis chess club and all the
support that Genie and Rex have uh
brought to chess in the United States
and St Louis I've had great memories
with the club from my Years playing at
the US Juniors I've played in three us
Juniors and before the St Louis chess
club the US Juniors wasn't nearly as
prestigious as it is today we have like
a field with an average rating over like
2500 these days which was absolutely
Unthinkable even like 5 years ago so
definitely I mean American chess is
really really growing these days the
amount of top players that that play
here on a daily basis is amazing like
just any great player you can imagine
has come to this club for example like
caspero uh Magnus vishy Fabiano like
everyone has played here it's such an
amazing Club one of my favorite moments
is winning the US junior Championship a
couple months back here and another one
could be like right after I became the
youngest International master I came
here I played I gave a Simo here that
was another that was another great
memory favorite memory was definitely I
became a Grandmaster in this club uh I
hit 2500 and I mean that's probably one
of the best days in my life so
far
yeah um it's amazing what the club has
done for chess in general because I mean
it's already been 15 years and they've
done countless uh national championships
tournaments for juniors helping gr
schools and they've just grown the game
so much across the United States I think
if I look at my own career and I look at
American chest in general we're in a
much better place than we were 15 years
ago and so so the contributions have
been immense and of course it's all
thanks to Dr Jun singfield and Rex
singfield I would say that s Lou CH Club
is like a rock in the ocean of Chess and
we know that it's it's there it is there
it will be there I think it send a hope
that the game of chess will always stay
Al flat by the mere fact of its
existence I think it it it sends
positive waves across the
globe
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States we
bring the educational benefits of Chess
to thousands of students across the St
Louis area we also promote Chess at the
highest levels hosting all levels of the
US championships as well as high-profile
tournaments that attract the world's
best players become a member and enjoy
perks such as free classes and lectures
weekly tournaments and so much more
visit St Louis chess club.org to claim
your membership
today the World Chess Hall of Fame
located in the heart of St Louis's
historic Central West End want to know
why chess has intrigued people around
the world for nearly 1,500 years stop by
and learn about the impact of Chess from
our three floors showcasing the art
culture and history of the game the
World Chess Hall of Fame has something
for everyone to enjoy for more
information on current exhibits please
visit world chess h.org
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85,000 students in both in
school and after school programs we
created the select chess training
program and the junior select chess
training program in order to elevate the
skill level in students across the St
Louis area these students receive
professional training from Grandmaster
vuan niobian other programs include
chess cops a partnership with the St
Louis Police Department looking to
improve relationships between atrisk
kids and police officers in the St Louis
area with over 600 students playing
chess over the board since
2019 the St Louis chess club has also
created a chess merit badge for the
scouts BSA quickly becoming one of the
most popular badges with more than
250,000 Scouts earning the badge since
2011 students of chess can also pick up
a copy of read and write chess thanks to
Club co-founder Dr jeie Caren sinkfield
anyone can learn how to understand chess
notation in no time we view chess as a
valuable educational tool learn more
about our Scholastic programming by
visiting St Louis chess club.org
SL
[Music]
education St Lewis the chess capital of
the United States boasts the worldclass
St Louis chess club and the World Chess
Hall of Fame it also plays host to an
award-winning shop dedicated to chess
merchandise All Occasion gifts and
plenty more at Q Boutique you can shop
both in store and online for chess
merchandise autograph Collectibles chess
campus souvenirs and much much more from
quirky greeting cards to luxury chest
sets there is something for everyone at
Q Boutique and all purchases go right to
benefiting new exhibitions and programs
at the World Chess Hall of Fame
dedicated to exploring chess and its
immense impact on art and culture
located on the first floor of the World
Chess Hall of Fame enjoy a shopping
experience like no other and become
everyone's favorite Gift Giver if you
can shop in store make sure to check out
Q Boutique stl.com for a wide variety of
gifts for everyone to
[Music]
enjoy the St Louis chess club is the
Premier chess facility in the United
States and is among the best in the
world thanks to co-founders Dr jeie
Karen singfield and Rex singfield the St
Louis chess club is a nonprofit
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess locally and
internationally we bring the educational
benefits of Chess to thousands of
students across the St Louis area
promoting cognitive development critical
thinking concentration and analytical
skills the St Louis chess club welcomes
chess lovers of any age and skill level
to come and enjoy the game of chess we
also promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the US
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sinkfield cup
Ken cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over
2,000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit St Louis chess club.org
to claim your membership
[Music]
today
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2023 national
championships they have been intense and
let's take a look at the standings with
just a few results here in round seven
and here we have the women's section so
k s won her game beging won her game and
they are Leaders with six points out of
seven they're just running through the
field it's incredible watching them and
in the open section
we have a few draws already um but still
Fabiano Corona is leading with four and
a half points and then we have a bunch
of players with uh Four Points Hans nean
Wes wi and Lenard Dominguez we saw all
draws yesterday and I think Hans Neiman
is a dead draw uh Fabby and Ray are are
ni and Tuck but that game looks pretty
might actually see six uh draws once
again really remarkable but one play has
turned the tide in her favor is Arena
Crush yes Arena this is the position she
made the time control that was the
question that was first point I mean 30
seconds for the last six moves or so
playing on increment that's not easy
especially in that very complicated
complex battle but right now this is
what we have in the position I don't
have to exchange the Queens No in fact I
don't think you should you shouldn't no
no no because if you do exchange the
Queens then the Knight actually has a
job defending the promotion of this Pawn
there's no Bishop takes D6 followed by
C7 and you have some problems Defending
Your structure agreed in the position as
white without the Queens you cannot take
advantage of the fact that my Rook is no
longer defending my king because there's
no checkmates coming in the position so
keep the Queens on the board how do you
do it Queen to E4 allows me to go Queen
to D5 so perhaps I don't want that maybe
just a simple Queen to C2 that defends
the pawn on C6 keeps the Queens on the
board and you cannot involve your knight
because you lose the Rook ouch so then
what do you do next if you give me a
check right maybe I can just go
back again it's all about check though
right you have Queen C5 now okay okay I
let's try something else in that case
King F1 allows Queen F3 check right but
then I can go King G1 so maybe that's
the way to do it so somehow kind of
dodging and weaving and bobbing I really
need to to to avoid this queen trade
right but H something like that yeah and
no checks anymore yes no more checks
right now right let's see what the
engine is saying okay Queen C2 we were
on the right track Queen C2 but now King
to H2 is the best move and in fact it
allows TR that makes sense because once
you trade the Rooks now I'm you can go
King G check and there's never going to
be any sort of Knight take C5 now Bishop
takes D6 is coming you don't have a rook
to defend against the promotion yeah
you're out take that's it that's it so
now I'm just simply going to be able to
use my extra Pawn after uh this trade of
the Rooks and in fact your queen still
has to stay around your king otherwise
you get made it the Knight cannot get
involved into play not very easy at
least so this is the winning sequence
for white still not that easy I mean the
white king is weak as well it's open
right mm exposed so it's still not that
easy it remains complex but from an
objective point of view ashita is in
trouble uh remarkable game by Alis Lee
such maturity at such a young age she's
playing against a four-time champion
Anna zatonski and Anna is tough she won
the kieren's cup uh one of the greatest
results of not the greatest result of
her illustrious career and Alice has
ground her down and is in a rook ending
where well white is simply winning this
Rook is behind perfectly behind the pass
B Pawn that means that the king is going
to come over but once the king gets
there white king does the same no you
don't want to go King D4 I was actually
going to go on the other side and just
win the game by playing um the
breakthroughs H4 G4
H5 you know so sorry so I mean you can
do that yeah your your approach would
have been if I can go back not back uh
yes yes uh and if I go back then you
wanted to put your king in front of so
if we could do something like this isn't
this a little bit awkward or oh you have
this Rook C5 check that was uh on my
agenda conversely I was thinking that uh
King E4 King D7 right just I was going
to put my king here and if you go here I
have a
check and I just go I just uh pose the
king side and also uh the the the
Breakthrough I had in mind was that the
king is just so um uh pretty right I'm
going to go F4 I'm going to go G4 I'm
going to go G5 and you don't mind losing
the pawn on B6 so maybe black has to go
with the King to E7 to just make sure
it's guarding the king side like stays
on E7 and that's where I use the pawn on
B6 as a decoy because eventually you're
going to just run out of moves right so
hold on uh King D7 King F5 King E7 right
something like this and let's say I play
H4 and then put my Pawn on H5 put my
Pawn on B7 and yeah I'll just try to
hold just King D7 okay H5 King E7 and
this is what I was uh this was my dream
was to play
F4 and
G5 and then eventually what I get is one
of those uh our producer Tom loves it
zuk I just move my rook and uh you've
got to allow I don't want to move the
king but I have to and King F6 exactly
yeah it's uh but wow uh to win a game
like this against Anna satony you just
have to go Alice and let's take a look
at her graphic because she is totally
remarkable extremely young age 13 I mean
come on
2471 and the youngest American woman to
achieve International Master title at 13
I was trying to win a b prize and I
think I actually won second in the B
section of the US Open in Chicago as a
13-year-old here she's an international
master and a future Olympic champion who
knows how far she will go by the way yes
this is going to be four in a row for
Alice if she wins this
one how do you call that well we know
theck but the four in a row what the
four in a row it's not castling
long it's castling on both Sid by the
way I think it's her birthday coming up
tomorrow tomorrow tomorrow she will be
14 years young wow um really by the way
are we having a lot of birthdays during
this us we lean Wesley so Al like who
isn't having a birthday certainly not I
but uh wow I actually know that later
it's Ray robson's birthday and also Nazi
pida October very popular month for
chess players yeah there was just lvon
as well uh where's the action in the
Sams games well I feel like Sam Shanklin
lost a bit of his Advantage yes this is
what we have right now he allowed this
Bishop trade I'm not sure if he had to
do it why not just simply all the s PA
he's a pawn up right right so why allow
complications and not just simply
control everything with a move Knight to
D7 control this entry via C5 I don't
want to see a knight landing on C5 I
don't want to see a knight landing on E5
so this seems to be this mirroring of
the Knight on D3 seems to be controlling
all of the important squares KN move
Bishop D5 King F I guess you can go
Bishop to E4 and I don't even have have
to take I can play the move that you
guys Bishop to
D5 thank you very much now your KN gets
out right right Knight F6 is coming you
don't have the threat on A5 anymore this
is an easy win technical win so he
played this move Bishop to E8 and he was
not in time trouble he still had 52
minutes at this particular Moment In
Time past time control but I think I
understand him because he's sitting
there saying H5 is dead meat that's p
number two I understand but I also have
Knight B8 maybe this is what he missed
Knight B8 and now we're trading off some
pawns you take H5 I take A5
okay okay that's what we have that's
what we have this is the position right
now no longer that easy in fact
especially after Knight C3 it's going to
be very difficult to Knight C6 par to
defend W I don't think this is winning
anymore you have to go back I go to C6
you go to D5 I go to F3 I try to stay
close to your pawns yeah let's say King
F7 right for sure as you mentioned A3
let's exchange I don't think you will be
able to promote uh these two pawns
before I can create my own Chances with
my B Pawn so right I'm looking at the
position and look Sam Sam Shanklin
didn't get the ruken game he got a minor
piece end game but unfortunately for him
wasn't able to control it well enough to
convert his Advantage by the way this is
one of those positions where as a human
player you immediately recognize that
the bishop on C7 is the wrong color of
the H Pawn which we've seen in the
tournament before already so anytime we
trade the knights then we can sacrifice
as white the other Knight yeah exactly
that's exactly what I I was going a
disappointing result for Sam shanglin
because he really played a good game
very good opening very good middle game
um handling unfortunately it was just
that move Bishop to E8 that spoils it
for him right now um we left it quite
some time ago I just want to catch up on
the game of Hans nean um because when we
thought I sorry I think it was exactly
right here we just looked at this
position you and I Kate and said oh my
God this is a completely completely dead
draw because there's no way that right
to push pawns uh but Hans it wasn't
willing to settle for uh a draw and once
again he is pushing the envelope but I
mean one has to admire these risky
decisions absolutely that's exactly what
I wanted to say C C4 takes and look at
this H is saying no I'm insisting on
playing for a win I may be wrong to do
so but on the other hand we've got to
applaud his uh desire to play for a
victory here right H H is one Pawn down
but his pieces are pretty active and
that passer on E5 can be dangerous but
will that be enough that's a question so
so let's try to set up some sort of a
fortress Fortress with Bishop E8 Bishop
F7 right Bishop uh okay you okay Bishop
E8 immediately because I I wasn't sure
if we wanted to play Rook C6 and provoke
Bishop C3 but Bishop Bishop doesn't go
back okay so the bishop so you're
wanting to put the bishop let's say on
the E6 Square put the Rook on C6 so
Bishop E8 just so that you don't have
any sort of checks from G8 from the
eighth rank I want to that's my Fortress
right here I also want to kind of be
ready for E6 a little bit better Bishop
E8 was
played okay you're you're channeling
your inner
Tang or his channeling Christian I said
it first yeah yeah yeah yeah who got in
there first uh I think uh you did I did
yes so Bishop E8 on the board and let's
just see uh should I be play well if I
play Rook C6 pardon me if I play Rook C5
and but guys I have a cool idea okay
please so Rook d8 that's what he played
yes Bishop F7 yeah rook
h8 and actually sorry First bishop C3
maybe okay let's say you play some
nonsense R C6 Rook C6 I go Rook
h8 not such a nonsense I go A5 you go
now there's Rook H6 wait um no if you go
King G7 now you go E6 so this is easy
well you can take I was I was trying to
set up a mate with E6 and Rook a you can
do that by playing after King G7 for
example which makes some sense now you
go E6 King G6 Rook H6 yes thank you
that's me okay yeah yeah this was the
mate sorry I was stealing your thunder
there Kate uh I was somehow thinking if
can you go one once again Bishop C3 yep
um yes six yes let's say Rook
E6 yes okay Rook E6 to stop H6 yes King
G7 and now I was wondering we can even
move like King H3 because I don't think
you can capture that Rook cuz then I go
E6 that's a discover check and a very
unpleasant one you have to go to H7
under I take the rook and promote and
now I capture the
bishop that's that's a killer and I'm
promoting yeah wait wait let's go back
for a second okay so after
E6 what yeah yeah keep going keep going
no no keep going oh oh I did it wrong so
after Rook h8 Rook E6 yes Rook H6 and by
the way they are playing so tell me keep
going in the line Rook takes Rook Rook
E6 yes no Rook takes Rook E6
right that was the line we were looking
at oh no sorry yeah King H3 we were
looking at yeah well Rook just to make a
move yeah yeah and now I take on E6 E6
H6 and E6 Rook take H6 then E6 wins well
that's that was my question uh I still
have King f8 right no because I captured
a rook and now Bishop
G8 o or Bishop G6 I'm not sure which one
is better because you don't capture that
Pawn mhm it's still very dangerous for
me because you do go with the King up
the question is who's uh who's first
yeah I'm just going to refresh my board
and I want to tell you they've played a
lot of moves uh when we ever since here
we saw the move Bishop E8 and just check
out how many moves they've been
playing uh and we've caught up with the
players now Rook C7 Rook to E8 Rook to
C7 Rook to to
E8 on the board so the idea is that you
cannot take on C4 that's why he didn't
take on C4 to pawn because the Rook
takes C5 so the just again to repeat
what you said so in case your white
wanted to take the pawn and why not
there was Rook takes E5 with a
discovered attack and then black is
perfectly safe so we do have this
position not oop excuse me we this is
our position yes I don't know this is
not that easy Bishop to B4 I put the
bishop on D6 I'm starting to grind you
down so Rook E8 Bishop B4 so your idea
is to give me a check I will answer it
with Rook E6 and then Bishop to D6 andh
and and Andrew has only 11 minutes while
Hans has 47 minutes that's right yeah
yeah no big time difference not that
easy okay says but Andrew says come on
I've got I've got how light sare yes
exact where's the break exactly show me
the Break show me I'm from Missouri the
show me state yes yes Rook E6 so shall
we show him let's put a bishop D on D6
okay and after Rook E8 maybe like Bishop
E7 or is your Pawn you cannot push C3
right I think I may have to because
you've got a you you've got a check in
mind no but then you're going to get
into some difficult
trapping pattern of the king okay now
that if you Bishop is on E7 you're in
trouble is on E7 I go Bishop E6 I have
to stop you from giving me the check
good
point and if I go you go on F6 I go back
to F7 that makes sense and now I go Rook
C3 Rook C6 I go Rook C Rook E6 same
business as before yeah and I'm not
accomplishing anything frustratingly
enough that is the case oh but Hans is
reaching for his Bishop let me just
refresh
my you might as well pick up the A6 Pawn
um in the meantime before you do
anything else I don't think you can do
anything as black you will have to allow
me to take that pawn on A6 well H
sweating it out uh so let's try again so
Bishop to D6 how are you picking up my a
pawn exactly Rook A7 Rook what Rook A7
Rook A7 ah well that was my question
because now
can
I uh try to go with a different Fortress
setup I don't know okay maybe bishop a
bishop B4 is A4 and then a check I don't
know King F7 now I can take on H5 no
sorry G6 I don't take on H5 G6 is a
problem G6 is a winner oh my so yes the
answer to your question is you can just
play slowly and pick up the a pawn but
that's fine let's let's take the a pawn
let's get the maximum out of the
position for white okay so we just it
seems like he just wants to keep the
Rook on E6 and E8 okay so go ahead you
won a pawn right but now
I I don't think I can go Rook E8 because
of Bishop B7 check so I have to find a
different way to pass the time let's go
King G7 okay
fair King G7 and I'll go Rook Rook here
or six yes okay help me out Kate uh
wait can I just capture the pawn now
Rook takes C4 then you you go Rook takes
E5 you don't take the bishop that would
be funny right Rook takes C4 would you
take the pawn or would you take the
bishop well we're taught that the bishop
is worth more than the pawn but this gu
is running away yeah is running oh yes
but Rook takes E5 is our
constant um answer whoa so you're saying
you
you're saying Hans can pick up the A6
Pawn for free right but then it's still
you know you've got to break the
Fortress well first of all it's still
equal pawns my pawns are looking very
ugly they are F5 H5 C4 I understand that
if you could just how the youu break
through if you could put that H the
break
yep so can I just start moving my king
maybe to D4 probably probably you should
try that once you get to D4 though
that's when I'm starting to push my H
Pawn right Bishop D6 on the sorry as as
white you want to I mean first I want to
pick up the pawn on A6 okay so so I
think we will wait for that but then
maybe to improve the king to D4 but your
King on H4 was doing such nice job if
you give me H4 and King H5 I can get
counterplay can't I um well we'll keep
an eye on this one I just want to check
in once again with with Fabiano uh just
to see how he is getting along in his uh
game with Ray and we've just seen the
move H well wait a minute this is
starting to look dangerous or fobby what
is going on the pawn I mean Pawn is free
on the H file so we are trying to push
it Forward yes indeed and if we take
take well this bishop is eyeballing this
Knight which means that uh H6 is doable
and that Bishop on C6 is just doing
nothing all white pieces are kind of uh
ready to support that pawn on H5 and
even a move like Bishop G6 check could
be disruptive and by the way
Sam's this one is over another difficult
game for Sam Shanklin he was winning
there and we see that he's very unhappy
with his
result well sometimes Sam comes on the
show and he complains vifer usly my
opponents are all trying to make draws
with me and things like and then
sometimes his complaints are accurate I
mean you know Sam seon really was on the
back foot early and uh struggled to make
a draw yeah Sam is definitely happy that
he saved this game that looked very bad
for him indeed and again we're we've got
the ray uh Ray and Fabby game and how
does the computer assess this I mean
it's I don't think White's winning but I
think it's White's for choice you have
to start making making difficult
decisions right now as black you have to
go Knight E4 it seems like Knight E4 yes
that's a very difficult move to make wow
so just give up a pawn for free I like
without taking on um H5 by the way
without taking on taking on H5 yes
Knight E4 first so in the immortal words
of Walter Brown immediately correct and
if you do take then if you do take on C4
I mean I do take on H5 and now I give
you a check on H6 on H6 you cannot go
Knight to E3 because F5 actually might
be worse for you okay so you have to
move the kinging king E2 doesn't work
because of Bishop B5 so you have to go
to E1 okay and now I go King E6 and it
seems like this is enough because I also
have the idea of Bishop to E8 Bishop to
E8 and take the pawn on H5 like that so
despite the fact that I'm for the moment
Pawn down it seems like I have enough
composition in this particular case but
Knight E4 played okay that's a very
important move yeah and not an easy one
to make because you're changing the
whole character of the
position H this move King E6 is annoying
for me I must say so instead of taking
the pawn does it make a difference if I
include taking on G6 you can take then
King takes G6 and maybe King G5 that's
right okay hold on so once again I take
on G6 you go King takes G6 I go Knight
takes C4 no I can give you a chance
truck because King G5 immediately I just
play Knight E3 and I keep you at
Bay right and even though that might be
a dry as well after Bishop D7 right
let's see just this this question is
who's faster with the pawns I guess well
I was hoping you do seem to be quite
fast right which is kind of problematic
yeah yeah going um all right so by the
way we do have
uh 94 check Bishop takes E4 on the board
we don't know of Ry Ry is thinking about
taking on G6 what does your intuition
tell you uh Kate would you take a as
white on G6 or because if you allow G6
takes H5 right Bishop H6 check and F5
and black gets two connected past pawns
as well yeah so white may be thinking
also about like Bishop F4 move just
improve that bishop and uh keep the
tension with the Pawns okay because now
I do want to capture the pawn on C4
because I don't worry about the check on
H6 anymore that's right I like that move
yeah so keeping control with Bishop F4
taking on G6 or taking on C4 immediately
those are the choices that Ray has
facing and how much time does he have to
Ray has 20 minutes Fabby has 17 minutes
so they still have a lot of time to to
think in this position guys I have to
tell you uh it's extraordinary to me we
saw some blunders at the end of
yesterday's games because they've been
playing five six hours I mean we've been
taking breaks we getting you know snacks
and you know even ourselves we feel
weary but these guys are making really
really difficult decisions with very
short time and a move like Bishop F4 I
would find extraordinary because I would
be like okay I could take on G6 and take
on C4 and I know I'm safe I don't know
if I'm winning but a move like Bishop F4
is is an attempt to play for a win uh
Christian absolutely no uh and uh Ray is
going to attempt that I don't think he's
going to take the easy way out with
Knight take C4 I think you know I have
to say I am always amazed to4 when like
players find a move like Knight E4 is
the best move in the position like you
are worse but you figure out how to find
that move that equalizes the position
absolutely and we have a special guest
in a studio Sam Shanklin with you
Christian Sam welcome back to the show
this was a very tense game but I have to
say you got a great position out of the
opening and you were playing really
really good uh moves when did you feel
like you lost control and allowed your
opponent back into the
game after Bishop C6 check I thought the
game would just win itself and then he
blitzed out king E3 at which point I
realized I cannot just go Knight D5
Knight C3 like I wanted Bishop to C6
remind us around which time was this
right here uh I gave Bishop C6 check I
can't see the B okay maybe you have you
have it on yours 42 or 43 yeah now I see
yeah so after yeah Bishop C6 check I
thought was a very bad move and after
King E3 I'm already I was already really
struggling to find a plan mhm like I
cannot just go Knight D5 Knight C3 I
don't think because he'll go A4 and I
couldn't figure out how I'm actually
going to do anything and his King is
coming to become annoying and it's it
was very difficult to come up with a
plan here maybe I should I think at that
point it was Knight
D7 um instead of the was Bishop C6 king3
the best move was Knight D7 I saw this
but after King D4 what's my next
move or Bishop E4 even I was not sure
about a bishop E4 I should just take a
knight F6 yeah this was probably a
better way and King F6 now or something
yeah King F6 maybe just Bishop B5 as
well yeah okay but this is not was
struggling to find a B5 um I think was
yeah and then yeah I guess there's never
Bishop E4 because it's always taken
Knight F6 yeah so I just undo the stupid
Bishop C6 from before yeah so Bishop I
thought Bishop E8 was winning but I had
missed an important detail and what was
the detail I think already it's just a
draw so I saw this KN C5 and I thought I
just missed that he's going night A6 I
thought he's going and then Knight B8 I
thought he was going Knight B7 instead
of Knight A6 that's what I had
calculated at least mhm uh Knight B7
here and then my point was after Knight
takes
H5 uh whichever Knight he takes on A5
with say Knight B takes A5 King D7 his
Knights are now incredibly stupid and
permanently stupid uh and they cannot be
fixed and I thought that I will win the
game with the H Pawn
routinely uh so this is what I had in
mind when I played Bishop E8 or at least
that's what I calculated but but I
missed that after King E7 Knight A6 I
just missed Knight C5 and Knight B8 I
missed and after Knight B8 I think
White's Making a draw
easily yeah so yeah because I was just
one time basically this position here
after Knight takes A5 go back to
it um yeah after Knight takes A5 I I
believe King D7 is the winning move
essentially and by this Knight B8 Knight
a knight A6 B8 business my king ended up
on the wrong Square uh is a good way
explaining it and that's one thing that
we were discussing uh as you were
getting miked up it's all these very
difficult decisions uh under tremendous
tension and pressure how do you deal
with
that I don't know I've been doing it for
my whole adult life I'm just I'm just
used to it I mean trust me you screw up
enough uh as much as I have in life you
you're used to making mistakes and you
don't worry about making more absolutely
you just uh pull yourself back up and
keep moving
yeah yeah sir uh no I just uh we've been
enjoying the tournament uh we had that
one round Sam it was immediately after
the free day where we had five decisive
games out of the six in the open section
and maybe it's one of those uh periods
where there's a lull six draws yesterday
and maybe we're going to see I don't
know six draws uh today how do you
explain that how do you get all decisive
games I've been the main contributor
because I should have drawn the game
with Dominguez at the end uh and I also
should have won this game so I was the
contributor to the 60's uh for sure um
but yeah I mean sometimes it's just luck
of the draw I mean for me I try to play
Fighting Chess every single game I mean
I I'm very risk-loving player these days
uh so you know but every now and then
games are just drawn I mean yesterday
like Dar has completely shut me down and
I didn't have a chance at all ever and I
was just worse at some point so you know
I'm I'm trying to fight every game I
think today I showed I was like ready to
fight with black like for example after
he played E4 in the opening like I
believe E5 is just a draw it's like D5
Knight B6 Bishop B3 Bishop G4 trade
everything big draw and I decided to
keep the game going even with the black
pieces when on paper draw with black
yeah kir E5 as far as I know is just
supposed to be draw making like three
more moves yeah um but I decided to keep
the fight going even with the black
pieces when on paper draw with black
against San is fine uh so I'm I'm just
trying to play combative Fighting Chess
every round um but chess is just such a
drawish game in its nature that
sometimes that's what you're going to
get and you got your chances and this is
exactly what we love to see here at the
US Championship very combative chess
thank you uh for displaying that Sam
we'll see you tomorrow yeah sure
absolutely and uh with this draw the men
standings uh or open standings so we
have still Fabiano Carana with four and
a half points and then we have hun nean
weso and Lenard Dominguez with four
points and Fabby is uh hard at work in
his game against Ray Robson while Huns
is trying his best to squeeze something
out of something or something out of
nothing against Andrew
tang and uh how is Al doing in her game
with Anna Zony oh she's wrapping it up
right now this one is completely winning
Rook to E4 and then I'm just going to
chaperone my Pawn down to promotion
there's nothing you can do you can
probably take the pawn but that doesn't
help you much we go to this position you
try to stop it I'll give you a check
then I promote next and that's it and
there's no way to stop me from uh doing
that you can try to go F5 but then I
just simply go back I stay on the E file
I stop you from from giving me check on
the E file and then I just push my Pawn
promote it and I'm going to easily deal
with your Pawn majority on the king side
so very easy very technical this Rook to
E4 I really like give away the B7 pawn
it doesn't really matter my D Pawn is
going to win me the game Alice
understands that and where's the sep of
the water I I think it's it's coming
right it's
coming wow wow uh just a really incred
performance I have to tell you I have
seen Anna zatonski crossing swords
dueling against the world's best ladies
and when she loses it tends to be a
tactical uh Skirmish she doesn't get
ground down like uh what Alice did uh in
this major piece ending and that would
be four in a row are we starting to feel
that she might be you know getting
closer and closer well she had such a
bad start but when you talk about what
beum and Carissa are doing against the
field you should be getting closer and
closer with four out of four somebody
not yeah I won four out of four games
but will somebody please stop trying to
catch up I mean four wins in a row
that's incredible but it still behind
Karis and be to here janova who are just
running through the tournament and let
me ask the S question how is Arena doing
because uh when we left it she was a
pawn up uh nursing extra Pawn here we
were we were talking about trying to
keep the Queens on the board if I
remember not so golden anymore not so
golden Jack wow this queen E5 that's a
visual right I mean okay it's a nice one
uh let's trade Queens says ashria not so
fast by the way your Rook is hanging so
on a good day allow me to uh take this
with a check if you take the night also
have to be careful about the queen A1
checks and queen A1 check is on the on
tap for black but I think this is the
key ashria recognizes that it's the
queen that's the problem piece that
she's facing so she's forcing the trade
of Queens with the move Queen B5 and
once we trade the Queens black is much
happier because the king is suddenly
safe on the queen side here also ashita
picks up the C6 Pawn which he has done
and yeah no the whoa whoa what is going
on not only is
it why isn't black the one suddenly
dictating Rook E3 Knight C5 Rook e 7 oh
thank you good well I was talking about
tiredness and mistakes and all the rest
but yes you for for a brief moment there
I I thought I was just simply winning
the B3 Pawn but but now having said that
why can't I threaten oh now now you're
in time but now Knight C5 I don't know B
B3 Rook takes B3 yes exactly are you in
time that was my
question uh King F7 and who's
playing who's playing I mean ashita has
to be very happy how it oh fantastic
theen trade the queen trade just
alleviated all the danger in the
position for black and if she gets
Knight C5 it's interesting we were
discussing this yeah we wanted to
exchange the Rooks not the Queens for
white uh White yes
yes and she decided to exchange the
Rooks but yeah this one right now okay
she's done who's in po position exactly
is the question well earlier I really
did like Ash's position I was thinking
look what king G4 whoa whoa whoa whoa
where is Arena going she's sacrificing
the pawn on B3 saying she wants to push
with the forward not yet because second
sorry I'm just doing a a quick uh so
there by the way the game is over here
Alice won her game B congratulations
four in a row by the way and it's not a
joke I mean you come into these national
championships it's so hard to win a game
I mean seriously so hard to win a game
you win a game you feel so really really
good winning four games you start to
feel like okay I'm on a really good
track right right right and uh also I
mean I I totally belong in this field um
what's is going we see that ashita as
and she has 28 minutes but Arena crash
only one minute on the clock what is
Arena doing excuse me did you just
blunder that pawn well no I mean she she
played her move very purposefully King
G4 did she forget that the Knight on B6
protects the C7 Pawn no I think she
wants to go King G5 Rook E7 and just
start pushing that g Pawn okay okay but
King g i I agree with you if you get
both King G5 and Rook E7 on the board I
I I'll support your your idea but that's
a check you're going to have to retreat
your king so you don't you don't you
know press my king back to the back Rank
and
eventually I mean I'm the one playing
I'm I've got an extra Pawn on so maybe
she missed this Rook B8 and just blunder
it wow wow wow this has completely
changed right now exactly with the Rook
on B3 so she played King G4 the last few
moves yeah look at her she she she
definitely has uh aspirations
aspirations yes I think that's a good
way of putting it she wants to go check
and in case of King F6 Bishop G5 check
and in case of Rook B5 five this is what
arena is
thinking that uh she will as as you said
uh push her GP but okay can I do this
and actually play Rook E5 now no no keep
going yeah yeah uh Rook B5 check Bishop
more or less forced if you want to
continue your attack Rook E5
exactly Rook E5 and then Knight C5
Knight E6 is coming oh yeah if you try
to avoid the trade of the rof and if you
do trade the Rooks I mean you're
definitely never winning this no I'm not
trying to win it anymore I'm actually
you're right yeah I'm simply trying to
draw it but did I have a choice like
where am I going where else am I going
to go with my Rook it makes no sense to
go to C4 Rook F4 has no purpose you're
just going to play your knight C5 Knight
E6 yes and you're very happy
yes yeah I like your move Rook E5 I
really do I think ashria
would recognize that but then again
after the move King
H5 how how threatening is the gepon May
I just ask the question what what are
you doing you're going to check me I
will give a check yes I will forcibly be
forced to retreat king of six we should
show it right yeah yeah just to uh
that's visual it's really nice that is a
that's a pretty Checkmate I don't even
know what it's called by the way that
one but okay I go back so you've done
your worst you you you you forced me to
the first rank but your Pawn is on G3
it's
not on G6 so if I go Rook D7 yeah I
think I'm very slow if you think about
it my a pawn is actually faster than
incredbly fast right and I mean I'm
going to come down here
and for white so asria is probably be
thinking after King H5 I can go Rook B5
check and Rook E5 and I've got us I've
got a two result game I'm not losing but
maybe with Rook takes A3 I'm winning
right and she has 25 minutes so she has
a lot of time to calculate which
variation she wants to play and before
she makes that decision maybe we can
take a look at the game Jenifer you
against yenu yangang exactly did not
spend much time here but it's a really
nice end
game okay there could be some
checkmating patterns so uh it's four
versus four but four versus three pardon
me and there goes the fourth there goes
the Queens sight Pawn go ahead some
checkmating I was thinking some E4 you
know the Rook G7 is going there Knight
Che oh sorry you're not playing Knight
f8 check because that would be easy M
could I'll would be very happy yeah
sorry uh how do I do this Rook G7 check
you were about to say yeah but I see the
Jennifer just played King F3 King F3 on
the board oh maybe she's trying to push
for G4 and create H passer makes
sense
okay um I tell you I would be a little
bit worried about G4 myself I might just
be inclined to to to shut that down that
that that's that's worrisome I would say
h g G5 G G4 and and
H5 this looks like it's heading towards
a draw uh let me go to let's go back to
the H game for just a second there was a
big moment just want to say in the tatev
game a game we haven't seen for quite
some time tatv is actually a pawn
down and a bishop is of the same color
ending yes uh bad news for Tatas fans
here and you saying we favored her in
the opening yes we did not anymore not
anymore sorry H but it's still not easy
right this one is still not easy because
those uh pawns for white on F4 and H4
they're perfectly placed specifically
because you have the pawn on F5 so
whenever you try to switch diagonals
with Bishop to C6 I will redirect to C8
put pressure on your Pawn on e4 right
that's my mechanism to try to make a
draw in the position at the same time
this is not going to be easy definitely
atusa has decent chances to potentially
win this one let's go back to the H one
all right there was a moment big big
moment at this point after the move
Bishop to E7 and it's very easy to start
looking at position and maybe go King to
G7 as well right okay and then maybe
bishop D6 okay why not Rook to E6 right
or if you go King to G6 Rook to E6 King
to E4 maybe you can go King to G G7
believing that Rook takes C4 is not
possible but guess what right now Rook
takes C4 is possible because with a king
on G7 if you do take on E5 that's a
check Che and if you do take on D6
that's Katrina's idea take D7 it's a
girl it's a girl there's no way to stop
so this was a big moment as well he
managed to spot it after King G6 Rook to
C7 this was it not King to G7 because of
Rook takes C4 he played The Right Move
Rook to E8 allowing Bishop to E7 I'm
blocking you a little bit right now mhm
but I have some more ideas Bishop to E6
Bishop to F7 King G3 Rook to E6 don't
touch this one right now you might be
losing Bishop yes now you're losing
right so Bishop to E7 Bishop to G8 it
feels like you only need me not to have
one more square one more square but I
still have that extra Square on G8
Bishop to D6 we're expecting Bishop to
F7
back one thing that Hans needs to do
right now probably he starts
understanding that this probably is a
draw but I need to get Andrew down to
his last few seconds right now he has N9
minutes on his clock and that's exactly
what Andrew is doing very well he's
playing moves but he's playing them fast
he's not allowing himself to go down to
his last few minutes so then you start
seeing ghosts you start getting worried
unnecessarily and that's exactly what's
happening right now Andrew defending
very very well and if he manages to do
so I have to say I feel Hans has missed
a big opportunity Christian can I go
Bishop f8 by the way just a question
Bishop f8 here M right so Bishop f8 I go
here and Bishop H6 okay so this is your
plan he's like you put your everywhere
on the board worri E7 D what if I
continue doing the same
thing um again the same idea you you
take you give me a check but I go back
right yeah you're right probably so this
rookie eight rookie 7even if you're
defending he's trying a lot of things
but unfortunately it doesn't seem like
it's working let's wait and see what he
comes up with Hans uh because we know he
will come up with something right he
just played Bishop E7 and we would
expect I don't know Bishop back to E6 I
think the other game is I think in the
game between Ray and Fabby uh a
repetition Bishop of opposite color that
seems to be the theme of the round as uh
weec a three move repetition in this
game and should this game should the
remaining two games be drawn well we've
seen 12 draws in a row in the open
section again coming off of the free day
everybody was full of yeah and it feels
like fire and brimstone tired after that
one round after the rest day they were
like okay that's enough now we need they
exhausted the commentators and
they they needed a break and by the way
coming back to the Arena's game um is
Arena losing we think she's over over
pressed her Advantage she had something
but now let's she just played the move
A4 what about Rook B4 so when we left it
we saw King H5 oh sorry when we left it
we saw Arena play King H5 King F7 by
ashria capturing that pawn on A3 and
just making it that much more difficult
for uh for Arena to play uh Rook E7 Rook
A4 Rook now by the way that was a
check and now Knight C5 Rook Rook A4
we're expecting Rook B4 right I thought
Knight
E6 you thought Knight E6 okay that
defends against uh Rook C7 targets the
bishop targets the bishop
although interesting I'm not sure it's
necessarily a threat I just don't know
know what I'm supposed to do here think
you can do G4 for example because then
I'm going to Checkmate
you another nice uh rook and knight uh
Checkmate that's a nice cooperation you
also canot move really the bishop
because then I take a free Pawn so what
is white going to be doing
here um I'm going to close my eyes and
go after this one guys why Knight D6
take a pawn why Knight E6 why not Rook
B4 I don't know I I that was my
inclination too I Kate thought Knight E6
was even simpler I I just because I'm
picking up another Pawn or we go into
this end game if this end game is just
simply losing then it's over right right
Rook A3 okay Rook A3 not Rook B4 Rook A3
and by the way weren't we talking about
arena being in Desperate time
trouble down down to her last minute or
so less than one minute and as has 22
minutes on her carock Rook A3 she has to
go Bishop D2 right Rook R1 where is she
going I can't guess Arena's moves I
really don't
know she wants to go Rook F1 yeah and
again she's putting all of
her faith I want to say in her G Pawn
but I don't believe it I don't believe
it at all Rook takes A4 Rook F1 King E8
and it's all asria but we have special
guests in studio Christian over to you
and Alice Le Alice uh back to your
Victorious ways a difficult start but
now you have won four games in a row how
are you feeling right now after
defeating such a marvelous
opponent I mean yeah uh this game I'm
really happy with um especially since
like in the end game uh like The Rook
ending I thought it would be a draw but
then I did some calculation around time
control um and then I realized that I
had I think it was probably a win like
um
I found like this work before move later
in the r ending and um I'm really happy
that I was able to win this game also
because I thought this game would be a
draw after like we traded minor pieces
um and got to the major piece ending but
that's one thing about defeating a
player like Ana zansky you generally
sometimes defeat her in tactical melees
you did the opposite it was a
strategical grind and you actually
managed to win in a strategical way was
that your uh idea from the beginning
What type of game were you looking for
in this
matchup I mean uh I don't think I was
thinking too much about tactical or
positional um I mean so I got a pretty
good like time Advantage out of the
opening uh I was pretty well prepared
and I think after that uh because of
that it made it like slightly harder for
her to play um and after like I was able
to I guess um get uh into my prep and
then uh she started spending time I
think that then uh it became slightly
easier for me to play and eventually I
don't think I was exactly winning when I
got like B4 in at some point in the game
but um it was definitely a lot easier
for me to play and then around time
control it's just like uh super hard
since she had like I had 30 minutes she
had 30 seconds well I have to say I'm
Blown Away by the maturity of your play
in this one in the competition as a
whole guys any questions for young Alis
absolutely I do have a question Alice so
you started a little bit slow I want to
know what happened after round three
when you started a series of wins what
did you change after round
three uh I don't think I changed much I
mean I kind of changed my shoes because
um my previous shoes are kind of
uncomfortable they my feet hurt but okay
um I mean I I've had like bad
tournaments before especially when I was
going to like IM am Norm hunting so um
for me like being able to come back is
like just about ignoring the past
results and then focusing on on the next
game and it's really great for me to uh
win of course four games in a row um but
of course there's still a few more game
that I have to play and uh the
tournament is not over yet absolutely
but congratulations on kind of picking
up and just winning four games in a row
yeah absolutely congratulations Alice
impressive indeed and it would be you
know give me the check for first place
if it wasn't for the fact that two other
ladies are doing extraordinarily well
Carissa and beum they're uh they're
leading Alice by a point and a half yeah
that's true even with four wins in a row
it's just wow um Arena I'm just kind of
uh stunned by uh her decision to go uh
with this whole King G4 stuff uh at the
same time those decisions they're very
very difficult and most difficult when
you have 50 seconds on your clock when
you have 10 seconds on your clock and
you have to make a move right and you
see all of these things and then you're
like okay what what am I doing yeah
we're we heard that with Hans when he
did the triple shift ight G4 ight G6
what do I put the night right it's the
triple twist the triple twist there we
go very important in chess the new
mooving chess the triple speaking of the
twist what do we think about this
position I think it's winning for uhri
how do we win it King E8 okay so King E8
finally I get to push my Pawn right
right uh but now you take my Pawn no
exactly it's not working uh let me show
you what you might have missed G4 Rook
takes and I'm hitting your Bishop I'm
stuck and completely stuck yes and if I
do this it doesn't really matter no I
really like this Knight on E6 oh the
Knight on E6 attacking the bishop just
defending also the king when we go to
the E play The Rook F1 we're expecting
King to E8 this is the money move right
now right just get out of the check and
there's nothing you can't push the G
Pawn it's an easy move yeah Bishop also
by the way I think you can go to E7 as
well I was a little yeah Bishop G5
Knight F4 oh no what oh no this actually
might be the way this game turns oh no
King E6 now the G PA but now finally the
G pawn moves away okay I still feel like
black should be
faster but this uh suddenly became a
Race So you go C5 let's say I give you a
check right right just to put King in
front of the pawn D5 okay let's go to G7
yeah let's yeah don't right G6 let's go
King f8 let's give a check you want to
give a check and then go back I want to
go check and put the Rook behind the
pawn I I I think she might be winning
this one as well yeah she's winning this
one as well the engine is saying that
this is winning wow but trading that
Knight for the bishop that looks risky
for me wonderful I would have not done
that no no the Knight on E6 that mean I
can always give up the Knight for the G
Pawn whether it be on G7 or whether it
be on G5 Knight on E6 is perfect and I'm
picking up the pawn on A4 G4 she played
it G4 on the board we're going to see
the race we're going to see the race let
me just bring uh again Arena's uh
position up on the
board by the way Hans is still trying
but not that much has changed we don't
have to go there just giving you an
update okay and I liked what you were
saying just for the uh check put the
king in front of the pawn and then just
push the
pawns uh the most
direct and we do have a draw between our
defending Champion Jennifer uh and ruang
in D5 G6 and this very nice move C4 it
doesn't matter either way uh King f8
Rook comes to h8 check
but can I also just play Rook
G3 and win it this way I suspect you can
and King E5 yes I suspect you can just
the two points are running really fast
they really are they're
fast suspect uh I suspect you can I was
I was giving a I was going to give up my
rook in a different way but the same
idea as you were saying there as well I
I'm ready to give up my Rook for the
pawn but I was also thinking get a few
more tempos yeah it doesn't matter
though it's not even close and one of
the things that you need to know in uh
the fight between the two pawns and The
Rook once the two pawns are on the third
or sixth rank yeah that's that's it they
promote by themselves they don't need
the help of the king or The Rook by the
way we see the Rook H3 check so ashita
is going for this winning variation yeah
D5 she started off with D5 so that she
doesn't have any sort of Rook E4 checks
I sort of like it yes no C5 impressive
C5 G6
C4 oh Rook G3 okay I think she's
borrowing a page from your book there uh
Kate uh Rook G3 is now a
draw what yes after the move G
unbelievable how is that possible so
C5 C C5 Rook to F6 that's the thing
and now you're kind of put your you
gummed up your
pawns that's
right oh you certainly ging them up C4 I
go King F7 now right and then G7 and the
problem is once I play G7 I threaten
Rook G6 as well this is the absolute
ideal position for white what she could
have gotten out of the last few moves
now the question is will I think Arena
will sense her opportunity because
there's no other move but why would you
play Rook G3 in that position just makes
no what what what a Miss no sense at all
I mean a push your Pawn King E5 Rook
C6 I guess she just wanted to play it
safe to make sure she can always capture
the Pawn With The
Rook she needs to play a rook C6 if she
goes King F7 then I go D4 Rook A6 Rook
A6 that's not it Arena that is not it
that is a shocking move now I just go D4
Rook takes A5 and uh you know I thought
you go even C4 and run with that pawn
you want to go C4 and run with this Pawn
surprisingly a draw but even with Rook
A6 Rook A6 is still a draw yes no way
really very surprising that this is
still a draw I mean it's so risky what a
move Rook
A6 wow how is that a draw so I guess now
you play Rook A8 or yeah that makes
sense yes yes Rook a I think is the one
and you're going to actually use both of
your pawns right now I guess maybe you
can I have to go Rook C8 first because
you were about to play C2 and Rook C3 so
I have to play Rook C8 yeah yeah Rook A6
is fine
wow after I King D3 you just start
running with your a pawn yeah mhh
wow wow Rook A6 draws as well as Rook C6
I'm stunned Rook A6 and just a second
I'm still like reeling so if I go
D4 Rook takes King Rook back right these
pawns I I was expecting the pawns to win
by themselves mhm but I guess that's not
the
case this is just amazing to
me
uh chess is
hard yep and then you and then you die
chess is a very very hard uh sport I
mean uh what does what does Willie
Nelson say you don't don't let your boys
grow up to be Cowboys don't let your
boys grow up to be chess players I mean
what the heck
and a quick look at the lady standings
and why this game is so important so we
have k s and be to Jan running away with
six points making a big kind of
difference compared to the other field
the players in the in the field yeah
Areno is trying to keep Pace with her
leaders but she's at four and we thought
she was losing now maybe she's drawing
and then she was winning and then she
Wasing again and tatev uh is actually uh
on the the worst side of an ending she's
still trying to draw that game as well
and what about Huns not that much has
changed um it's still a draw it's still
a draw Hans is still trying and he's
going to try for a little while but it
does seem like Andrew is cracking in
this one is not cracking he he's not
cracking at least not as of right now no
but again still 23 minutes for Hans we
know he's going to try until the very
last moment
sure okay what do we do now do we go
Bishop
F7 by the way just a update in the
Arena's game ashri had uh did try to put
her faith behind her C Pawn she's played
C4 Rook takes A5 C3 on the board I think
we should go to that one just because
it's much
more I mean it's a hot potato going on
over in this game uh and we always like
this type of races Rook
C5 as
The Rook goes behind the Pawn King D4 is
a very expected move exactly and
actually could be also King D6 but
that's more passes right can King
D yeah you know this is one of those
moments where I go crazy you go she goes
King King D6 by the way in the game
imagining King D4 the computer says Rook
C8 draw loses Rook C7
and then you try because Rook C8 is the
drawing move right you look at it and
you go that's the move I would play was
Rook C8 by the way King D6 I'm starting
to worry for ashita no no no but why we
shouldn't worry about ashita no why I
think she's doing well Rook C8 what do
you why if you go D4 A5 A5 King
D7 Rook C4
D3 okay
A6 no no no no no no no no no D2 I'm but
then R D4 so maybe you can go if you
want A6 maybe I don't
know by the way D2 maybe I can even go
A7 you don't have a check you get the
queen first but you don't have a check
after oh my gosh and you might actually
lose that no then I would have to check
I would I would sacrifice my rook and
queen oh queen queen E4 Queen E4
yeah we continue the game we continue oh
my gosh you might be able to find a way
to get that Rook but it's not clearcut
I'm sorry I'm just going to uh update my
board King
D6 maybe ashria should just not push her
luck anymore I mean King E7 Rook C5 I'm
starting to worry I was about to say I
mean it could be you know another uh all
right so there's one way to lose if you
go D4 I go A5 yes yes now you go D3 yes
now A6 and you're done well that's what
I what we've been looking at right that
was how we lose but what's amazing to me
is that we should be losing this
position as black I mean these two
connected past pawns can I give up my
Rook for both your pawns and make an
easy draw but all of that was so
unnecessary I mean oh no it really was
this going to really hurt oh my gosh dra
this game after such a winning end game
right and and it all went wrong with
Knight takes F4 I believe so because the
Knight was really good defensive piece
the bishop had no business really doing
on the king side by the way alert
everybody the game suddenly became a
three result game after this move D5 D4
M D5 D4 A5 yes A4 A5 A4 A5 now you
better not play D4 uh D3 D3 excuse me
yes yes okay so what does she want I
guess she wants Rook to a rook to G5
right well that's right that must be her
idea yes I suppose you're right but wait
a minute now I go Rook d8 Rook d8 check
though right your king will cut the
action on the fifth rank of your
Rook I don't know guys I'm I'm starting
to get can I go King E6 here no if we
can continue that game King E6 in this
exact moment yes I cap you capture the
pawn I capture the pawn that's what I
would hate because I want to give check
on A7 and then I give check on A7 yeah
King H6 I don't know are you sure you're
I was thinking you're going to go King F
then I have King F6 yeah I'm not sure
you're drawing this I'm not sure you're
drawing yeah King starting to get
worried uh I'm not sure you would be
drawing this one either Kate I mean this
one uh again uh The Rook it suddenly
White's Rook ended up in the perfect
location here jeez d4's on the board and
not maybe
Arena Arena Must Be Wondering what
what's going on in the position because
doubtlessly what arena is worried about
is A5
D3 Rook takes question mark D2 and she's
worried that the queen and she's worse
right that she could lose this game
so she's seeing ashria playing D3 and
maybe that's the same uh line that
ashria is calculating but maybe Arena
will say well if I can't take the pawn
can I make a let's try to pull the
brakes with black how do we pull the
brakes with black after A5 let's try to
find at least a draw exactly we we've
been losing a lot of these Pawn races
with black right now yeah
congratulations on losing the pwn I
would you know if I would if you told me
look shut it down and uh make a draw A5
I'd go C2 King F King King F7 I can't
guess anything geeez King
F7 okay Kate
explain so I'm I would be running
D3 isn't black winning
now
um and if you go
G7 okay then I go
C2 okay that's winning that's winning
and then it's Unstoppable that you're
going to make a
queen Fair okay so uh help help uh all
right so I I think we have to go King F7
was that a
blunder I don't think so it wasn't not
yet so keep going D3 let's go Rook takes
C3 I think we have to go into this you
have to go into the queen versus the
rook and pawns yes now the question is
do you want to give a check
first what on F3 perhaps ah try to uh I
don't think I want to give the check for
the king in front of the pawn because
then The Rook will be able to go to F6
okay to give check to me okay Rook F3
was by the way Rook F3 check King
e what's going on now it's starting to
get a little bit
wild who's playing for a win here it's
starting to get starting or it's I guess
it's been going it's been getting Wild
For King
E8 okay but now I I can go Rook to G3
right well that I have at least a draw
we know we understand that maybe but I
thought I'm playing for the win I did
too so I go D3 correct D3 we were going
to take the pawn no no no no no no now I
go g
right G7 am I not the first one
promoting now yes you are sorry once you
go Rook G3 then I take on C3
right but this is still a draw because I
give you check on E6 then captur the PA
and yeah I mean you you can you can just
make a draw the most direct way as well
which is just to take and take and then
you will make a draw so we think ashita
still has a draw in her pocket yes but
wow
it's been a hot potato with the half
point being tossed around like there's
no tomorrow so what would have been the
outcome if asria had not played Rook F3
if if if she had just gone for the
queen would would she have been winning
this uh or
not what does is is this a table base
uh I believe that's a that's a draw as
well yes it's it's a draw yes yes yes
wow
why so remind me again D3 D3 no I think
it was King E8 the king is actually on
E8 because she took a she gave a check
oh yes un say she would have I wanted to
ask yes and queen yeah this is still
this is still a draw Queen now G7 Queen
D5 Queen G5 Queen D5 king um
G6 I need to get close I need to get
close to my King the excuse me yeah no
because I give check on e4 and if you go
to H5 I have check on H7 yes once I get
close to my uh Rook there's no way you
can do anything is there any chance of
transferring my king to G8 and that's
fine and then also no but there's no way
I'm just staying there staying with your
King next to your Rook yeah and then I
can't separate them
right
maybe maybe yes crickets
don't don't believe me wow uh what a
game but for arena uh let's say
hopes uh she really had to come in today
cuz look again ashria is sitting at the
bottom of the uh the cross table with a
single draw after absolutely and if Ina
wins she's trying to catch up to Karissa
and Pim but uh she would be very
fortunate as it turns out to draw this
game and uh it still feels like somehow
it could be a three res game because I
mean something these ladies are
exhausted something might happen I know
it's it could be magic is any magic
happening in Andrew tangs not much no no
we still not that much has happened yet
and the problem is you might be thinking
hey I can take the pawn on H5 but
exciting not really not so
exciting not really you cannot take that
right so so Bishop to d8 but look again
he's poking he's trying to find the hole
in the position it's just not happening
Andrew is playing a really good
defensive game right now
yeah that move King takes H5 reminds me
of his little video I saw with the mouse
happily jumping around and then snap the
mouse tra and you're dead that's right
it's like oh my gosh m one king takes H5
and uh back with Arena crush and and
ashria for a moment here as we're we're
seeing Rook check King just came back to
F7 so there is uh a draw in
hand uh with the move Rook F3
check and by the way if Arena drops this
game MH going into the last four games
right the two co- leaders will have a
one point point and a half lead over the
rest of the field right that's
significant that that that is truly
significant with only four rounds to go
it feels like it's slowly but surely
becoming a two horse race at that point
yeah because again Karissa having won
over Alice Lee that uh that's a very
very significant victory for her she
played Alice Lee beging played Alice Lee
as well right of the top four it's only
going to be beging against Arena that
haven't played against each other
exactly looking at so again if you see
Carissa at the top she's played beum
she's played Arena she's played Alice
did Carissa play Anna
zansky I don't think so so Anna is and
then she she just played Talia we know
she's going to play atusa as well so
Carissa well at this moment her chances
of winning National Championship looking
very good yeah maybe let's take a look
at the game between TF abrahamyan and
atusa Pur kashian because atusa has that
extra Pawn with Bishop
endgame um but TV is trying to defend
yes with this it sure does look good for
atusa I must say You're Gonna Play
Bishop B5 you're going to play uh C4 at
a certain moment you're going to force
this trade and then your king can come
up and play Nurse Mate no but you also
have to be careful about the F5 Pawn
right
right okay so at this exact moment King
D2 on the board uh black to play let's
just take a look shall we so I I want to
play
C4 so you can't take the pawn on A6
that's a discovered check but I could
play first king E1 can I do that oh I
cannot
let
me okay let's let's show it to viewers
KY W okay so you're attacking the bishop
you're attacking this pawn and you're
attacking this pawn and if you move the
bishop to D3 which you're not going to
do right uh and you would love to play
the move Bishop E4 but yes so this is a
way to lose it immediately exactly but
you were about to tell me that the pawn
on F5 is not so easy the moment I play
King D6 you want to uh
tickle me right right so you would
presumably I don't know King just hang
hang about okay so where could I go one
thing I'm kind of happy is as white that
all my pawns are on dark squares yes so
you can't really attack them uh with the
bishop exactly so let's have a look so I
go here here here takes now I pause
because although I am patrolling this
diagonal um how do I get my
king
to you know how do I how do I escort
King B5 yeah let's take a look yes King
B5 well I've got King B2 so you're not
you know what I'm saying you're not
squeezing around and
if if um tatev can play this one why way
T she played King
E3 in the game mhm okay did uh yes
captures C4 captures captures I see so
takes takes and she put her King oh of
course I'm going to play King C7 just to
push your Bishop away from the C8 square
right but can I now play King
D4 no that's a lost end game right you
can capture the
bishop King C6 and then King
D5 yes and actually I'm going to go
after the a pawn not even the but that
doesn't matter you're not going to play
King D4 you have to move your Bishop so
F3 okay good but now atusa maybe she's
finally uh getting ready to realize this
uh Pawn how do I do this B3 King D2
correct
M
okay
wow I like that King on D4 if I can get
my king to D4 uh I'm definitely more
confident about my
position okay uh let's go let's see it
King D6 King D4 Bishop B5 just waiting
so Bishop
D5 Bishop to D5 just
waiting
yeah Bishop A4 you're going to go Bishop
B7 I'm not happy so Bishop E2
um so Bishop B7 okay so finally am I
ready to
rumble B3 King c33 Bishop back Bishop
here yes
yes but maybe as you can even instead of
Bishop C4 can you go King
C5 yes so King King
C5 you give me the pawn but then you get
your king to D4 and that's nice I mean
so long as I'm keeping my pawns on A6
and F5 protected I'm doing very well MH
King E3 King takes
F4 tatf still has a lot of work ahead of
her I I want to go back to the arena
Crush game because I just feel
so so defeated in my understanding uh uh
she played D3 check this out Jack King
F7 she avoided the repetition which she
could have uh claimed with Rook F3 and
she played D3 okay what about Rook d8
now Rook takes C3 oh Rook takes C3 okay
all right I think you were mentioning
that you you didn't like the fact that
that white could bring her Rook to F6
right
so
D2 what else can give check on F F3
but I don't know how helpful that is and
to
whom
indeed D2 the same and well this is the
same ending that
um and she did give the check on F3 by
the
way
so in one line we put our Rook on G3 in
other line we can put our Rook on F7 you
know it's funny I at one time I went
through this whole it was the Auerbach
endings I don't know if you had these
books by uh Yuri arbach all of these
ending Bishop endings Knight endings
Rook endings and and stuff like that and
I did look at Queen versus Rook endings
and I was so happy to understand how to
win with the queen against The Rook
right because that was hard winning with
a queen against rook and a pawn I didn't
want to bother especially when the pawn
is close to be promoting right you know
it's just hard enough to win with the
queen against The Rook queen against
rook and pawn I just always and there
was these certain moments where you
thought the pawn as it was moving up the
board then you were losing the game it
was like the pawn was better on G2 than
it is on G4 four like if the because the
queen comes behind the king it it was
really you know as a as a teenager
trying to understand that ending that
was just close to
Impossible uh so ashita has a queen and
Irena kage has rook and two pawns I'm
just going to update my board because
the players have reached the position uh
how do we feel about this position do
does she have chances I mean I you from
an objective point of view this is a
draw but how are her chances I don't
think white really has chances because
the blacking is too close to the
pawn
no we think black has chances Oh Black
full stop end of story why is trying
desperately to draw there's no question
about that now the question but how can
you ever get closer if I keep my Rook on
F7 but the Rook F7 I go kingly E6 right
yes what do you do now King
G7 okay so I go check and I take a pawn
okay you can I'll take that pawn at some
point but now how are you going to make
Improvement she's going for it okay Rook
to F7 check H7 I'll would be just moving
King G8 H7 G7 a G8 H7 so this is the
this is the point if the pawn was on G2
it's an easy draw with the pawn up the
board funly enough you might get
yourself zuk zong how would we do it um
how would we do it so you're saying I'm
going to put my king on H7 G7 or G8
those are your squ I'm not going to make
any other moves
correct
uh so by the way the players are
reaching Queen takes
A4 so I can for example in this
position uh how do I do this I can make
it your move right but you have to play
Rook F6 okay then I have to give check
right so for example I can go uh I'm
just going
to make it your move and then great big
big deal right M you've got uh I made
you make a check so I here the uh oh
it's the time guys clock clock clock
clock clock clock clock clock clocks
clock clock clock King G7 okay she
couldn't push the pawn she has six
seconds left okay when she did that okay
um here Kate this is this is how you
lose King G8 Queen H6 right our analysis
that is how you lose the game but
whether or not a shria can force that is
a completely different question so if I
could play if youing g g Queen H6 and I
go G7 what you do do
next what that you you have
G7 I'm thinking that I might have it I
don't know okay I'm just pushing but I
didn't manage to keep that for Tress as
I thought it I will no you're always
getting kicked out yes yes so you're
saying uh Christian if you don't mind me
saying it let's put that position
somehow if okay King H7 king queen H5 G
Queen H6 here here here here we we we
get the position and you said to me G7
right can't I play and now King h8 right
I was thinking King f8 mate right right
king h8 of
course it's still not over because you
do give a check on H3 that forces me on
G8 but I don't see how you get closer
it's like one of those long distance
right the king h8 that is always do king
h8 yeah
wow you never know what you're going to
learn on a chess program queen queen
versus Rook endings let's get the king
somewhat closer so let's go Queen C3 for
example Queen C3 or let's give a check
first queen H3 King G8 and now King E6
right right so King closer our King's in
the
vicinity so by the way guys the players
are kind of following our analysis and
getting into that position they're
they're they're heading in that
direction with the
queen trying to overcome the rook and
the
pawn so her idea right now is she's
going to try to keep the King on G7 not
G8 because she wants to give whenever
King to E6 comes on the board she wants
to give all sorts of like Rook F6 Rook
F5 or Rook F6 Rook F7 Rook f8 checks
right if the queen tries to Swerve away
from E5 exactly so maybe King E6 now yes
okay that's that's the testing move I
feel King E6 and I think you wanted King
G8 uh uh Kate now Queen
H5 and King
G7 right and King
G5 Queen G5 Queen G5 and so you were
saying no let's go Queen
H4 okay because now the king doesn't
have work to go right right and that
keeps an eye also on F6 so I don't get
to play Rook F6 I think this is where I
managed to force you to play G7 finally
you got but then I didn't this is not
the because Queen
G6 this is not the same position though
so this might be a bit testing Queen H5
or do you put a rook
now wow
I don't know I don't know and playing
with only increments it's that's what
worries me it's incredibly hard uh for
arena by the way how much time does AA
have she has six minutes and Arena Crush
has one minute that's comfy that extra
that six minutes I can set up some traps
and you know calculate a few moves ahead
whereas Arena has to play well with 30
seconds right right by the way I think
uh atusa bashian is winning uh her game
because she's getting into that endg
game position that we talked about right
the bishop is on C well but King C5 King
B6 I see and by the way uh ashria is
going for that position and we're
expecting Queen H4 which he's just
played M uh following your advice
coach giving you an update on the Hans
situation nothing has happened still
still a very similar position to where
we left it
so that's like
the Saturday Night Live it's I'm going
to give you a partial score uh Missouri
Tigers have 15
right in like uh 30 minutes they still
have 15 they the other side has exactly
the same score and uh Arena Rook okay
f8 are the walls closing in a little bit
Rook f8 that doesn't spoil anything
right no I Rook
f8 because we were looking at King G8
Queen H6 but Rook f8
seems
safe
I'm I'm a little bit uh mystified here
how Okay so Rook f8 so imagine I give
you a check Kate I'm imagining your king
going to G8 right
right so if I just wait for a second do
you want to play G7 or not am I I prer
not to I prefer to back Rook F7 and you
you waiting for black to somehow if it's
possible to force the pawn to G7 because
the Rook is really nice cutting off the
black king who cannot do anything and
once I push the pawn The Rook is kind of
weakened yes
Fair it is very fair
tusia tat in trouble Bishop can come to
D3 Black's Bishop is coming to D3 and
King E3 tat really big trouble we let's
take a look at that game yeah sure let
me no I think she's doing fine is she
doing fine yeah I mean they you going
play Bishop D3 just Bishop CU if Bishop
takes and King C5 yeah I think she's
fine but I thought I'm faster as
black are you shall we take a look
because she didn't
challenge so take that
pawn and I presume go towards the pawn
yeah G3 maybe yeah G3
Fair
B6
we both Queen right yeah actually white
Queens
first still slightly better for black
but because you're closer to the pawn
but should be a draw agreed at the same
time it's something to play for okay
that didn't do it she went Bishop F1
Bishop back to B7 and I'm just going to
uh refresh my board
everybody and Bishop F1 Bishop F1 just a
second what do we have you have Bishop
F1 Bishop B7 Bishop H3 Bishop C8 Bishop
back to F1 so if I go King E3 now it's
the same
thing I assume it is we're getting the
same ending if I trade Bishops right on
A6 no I got a Tempo
here so I trade the Bishops you did and
then I promote first and you win which
is a big difference because I
can trade queens and I'm very happy my
king is going to capture that pawn on H4
and that is winning I think it's still a
drop but what king B6 right but you do
get the
pawn this is drawing I mean you get the
pawn but theoretically I think this is a
draw wow again it's not going to be easy
you're going to suffer for a very long
time
wow but I don't think I have have to do
this go back for a second I feel like I
I've got big holes in my ingame
knowledge here me too and uh they're
cavernous uh go back where when you
instead of taking on A6 can I go King
C7 that's an intriguing
move you're ask and to be honest if you
go
bishop6 yes I might even go King D6
and it looks like a draw has been agreed
actually yes wow okay all right that's a
good decape some questions surprised I
thought atusa was going to try to push
more but maybe maybe it is wow okay big
surprise and going back to the arena
Crush game because we do have this
situation where if the Rook goes to F7
now we could put our King uh on E8 it
doesn't mean it's getting to f8 anytime
soon that's a big moment because the
question I I keep asking myself is it
good to push the pawn to G7 or not I
mean did you see what Ina just did she
grabbed the White Queen maybe getting
ready toot it's com it's comforting to
have the queen in your handti and you're
about to promote right that's truly
ambitious just to make sure you put
pressure on your opponent because you're
saying hey I'm going to promote I need
this queen right
nice well to be honest now can you just
simply go G7 and then keep the King on
G6 and H6 that's that that was my
question did the did the table base tell
us whether or not a draw yeah yeah no a
draw it's still a draw yes with the pawn
on G7 or G6 yes G7 was fine okay but now
you know Rook F7 King E8 and again King
G8 so we are expecting maybe Queen D5
just is bringing the queen closer but
then your idea King G7
right by the way let's take a look again
how Arena how how she grabbed that Queen
that's a typical chess power move right
right there an off theboard power move
give me my
[Laughter]
queen I was like you're not getting that
Queen on the board come on you know that
I know
that uh who it was this one I think it
was in the Junior it was Elia nishik he
was a junior player when he was eight
years old he had his teddy bear and he
would come to the board with his teddy
bear it was his comfort animal right his
protection the queen you know Queen
she's holding it this uh she's got she's
ready to Queen uh a draw in this one
Hans nean very uh he's been pressing
pressing forever and ever nothing has
changed no AB has changed yes and we can
look at the position by the way I mean
he he tried to bring the king to the
center but outside of that nothing has
actually but Andrew is getting lower on
time right it's five minutes now that's
the key yeah get him down to his last
few minutes maybe then you get the
chance exactly now but you see he
brought the king to D4 I did think that
is one of the strategy to just continue
playing for something exactly uh I
thought the problem of bringing with the
King to D4 is that at some point black
might play the move H5 H4 shall we have
a look at that sure let's take look if I
play H4 how would this but if I go Rook
H3 don't go King
H5 because you're going to sacrifice the
I'm going to capture that pawn very nice
that is because unluckily for black uh
for Andrew pardon me the bishop is uh
perfectly
misplaced so uh in this exact position
on the current position we have Bishop
E6 on the board uh sorry not H4 Bishop
E6 so if I had this position let's say
and again if I'm just going to make a
bad move uh pardon me isn't H4 a threat
or not because boy I see the way I see
it you know I've got a
passer okay I'll give you do a pass G
Pawn but I can deal with that you know I
was thinking that if let's say you play
Rook C3 I go Rook A8 and then I'm going
to ask you do you really think you are
the one who is put no I don't think that
the Rook The Rook belongs on C3 on the
contrary I think the Rook is you know
trying to play to the seventh as well as
the sixth ranks with Rook A6 so I Rook
A3 Rook A3 C3 terrible move but if it it
was I'm just asking the question if it
were black to move hfor definitely
disturbs the equilibrium I think there
might be a 50 move rule here coming up
too because we I don't know when the
last pawn move was Rook takes A6 so
let's say we have Rook H4 pardon me pawn
H4 uh yeah well we have to yes yeah
let's say Rook C3 random PA H4 yeah Pawn
H4 Rook H3 okay King up and now
G6 yeah but then aren't I Trading
nicely the the the the H Pawn for your G
Pawn by the way Rook G7 on Rook A7 on
the board probably forces Bishop F7 I'm
just going to refresh my board for a
moment Rook G7 probably Bishop
F7 when was the last Rook takes A6 was
the last capture yeah correct so I'm G
that was some time ago though right I'm
going to take a look what number was
that right
no and now we're at move 95 15 moves no
sorry that was Pawn takes on
C when was the last pawn move or Pawn
capture or when was the last pawn move
or
capture it was at move 62 62 and now
we're at move 96 so we need another you
guys do the
math come on you're my top agent of
these I think it's 15 I'm going to go
with 15 that's that's only because our
producers are telling us that I don't
know with Tom man I mean he throws us
these curve balls every now and then you
know we believe him we believe
him believe all right so 15 well that by
the way that would influence me not to
play the move H5 H4 if I was in Andrew
shoes because that would completely uh I
guess at some point you're going to go
some King C5
right is that how you want to make the
push the final push for that Victory
King
C5 yes or is it the final push for a
loss yes after H well you do give C3 as
well right I
mean you you you start to wonder
you know are you losing control yeah you
have to be careful about not over
pushing the whole right it's is C3 an
issue after King C5 C3 is an issue yeah
oops Yeah yeah you might be in trouble
okay so King C5 if that doesn't work
then how okay you got your king to D4
yay manage to change the position what
do you do next right well like you were
saying I mean I think it was really the
entire intention of that was to to uh at
a certain moment have your King on D6
and you know through the magic of look
at my hands look at my hands uh I would
get to play E5 E6 in those
cases uh but I just don't see how we're
going to get
that by the way we have an interesting
position now in uh Ina crash and ashita
asron
game because Queen H six happened okay
that was uh that was how
AA was going to try
to because I think that was the only
move for Rook F6 that actually
Drew really no so we did get this this
moment of auk Swang and as we were
saying Queen H6 so G7 but I thought G7
was drawing because after Queen E6 uh
Christian has suggested King h8 if I
take the rook and it's a promotion but
she did play by the way Rook F6 and King
E7 on the board now you're starting to
see some ghosts as white okay you go
Rook F7 right right King
E6 well now now we go this D6 or King D6
yes to ask that question with Queen E6
King h8 are you see king h8 or are you
going to get scared about it yeah the
moment you see mate in one you
definitely have a fright right yeah but
being in ashita shoes I don't know if I
want to be risking King D6 I feel like
I'm moving away from that pawn I don't
want to lose this game oh no oh
[Music]
no so we do have King E7 on the board
we're expecting Rook F7 and
G7
by the way that's probably a loss right
yes okay big moment right now how much
time does Arena have an hour sorry a
minute and 30
seconds would
this if I could ask just a A funny
question Rook F6 check would I be losing
after King E5 King
F7 um uh guys in the table base is Hans
better sorry not Hans Andrew better
after this move Rook to A6 and H4
potentially that's a question I've
always asked if I'm in Andrew's shoes
I'm aspiring for H4 right so that one
might be exploding sometime soon as well
but Andrew just played Bishop E6 yeah I
think he's not taking any risks as
opposed to Hans he just wants to make
that draw he's low on time it's so
difficult right I mean you've defended
the whole game and now you play H it up
perfectly probably not you're going to
go B B6 which he did but had he played
H4 you were about to tell get a little
bit tricky yes yes H4 is not that easy
now because King H5 King G4 comes fast
right and you're not stopping me anymore
if you go King E3 then I use the other
Pawn as a decoy yeah and I believe this
was the idea if you do go Rook to C6 now
I go H3 and if you do try to catch me
you cannot because of Bishop to D5 right
Rook on C6 is badly placed nasty that
was the key okay he did not play it he
played the move Bishop B6 King to E3 and
now we're getting closer and closer to
that 50 move rule because none of the
pawns have moved since Rook takes A6 40
moves
ago
right so they have only three more moves
to do and then then it's 50 moves am I
correct 62 all the way to 112
right correct and right now we're at Mo
100 after Bishop D5 Hans is going to
play Move
100 Bishop E7
check wait a minute what what just
happened probably
nothing probably nothing probably
nothing but okay okay so you go King G7
I would assume right or King to F7 yeah
I would assume King F7 okay King F7
let's go here how do you set up the the
defense again Bop E6 Bishop E6 was our
go to and then King to G uh6 yeah yes
that was our setup it's still there our
Fortress it's still there nothing has
actually changed uh what did Arena do
did yes did she make a move um what
happened in that one whoa uh
okay so she did
go
G7 what king was on E6 okay Rook F7 King
E6 G7
okay so after all of the finagling uh
ashria managed to achieve her maximum
which was to force her opponent to
advance the pawn to G7 and now after
Queen H5 The Rook has to go a little bit
further away right from the king so this
was her goal and she's achieved it okay
but now uh now that you mentioned the
Rook has to go away from the King MH
where do you put it F1 or A8 I want to
get it as far away from the action as
possible Right it seems like all of the
moves with the Rook that don't blunder
The Rook in one move make a draw okay so
you're still fine no matter what you do
wow there you
go very exciting game this one
up and down wow theoretical rook and
game now Queen again Rook against rook
and and I thought I I rolled the rode
the roller coaster yesterday and the tat
Talia game this one is another wild ride
I'm just holding
on as uh as the car is shaking uh across
the tracks Rook F1 um on the board just
before could to ask you would you go to
the other Corner Rook A8 or would you
choose Rook F1 I think Rook F1 makes the
sense to keep the king cut yeah and if
black goes now Queen H4 just to stop
check on E1 and you are not able to play
King f8 because then there is the one
move check made yep so you have to move
the Rook
again yep but here I get to play Rook f8
back right where it's nice and protect
and this is where the move Queen H5
forced me uh to move my Rook all the way
back down again okay I went for King E7
mhm after inviting Rook check a little
bit before Rook check I go King D6
right I don't think you want to give a
check by the way allowing me maybe to go
to G6 and then to hide to
H6 sorry what do you mean you mean if I
had if I checked you a moment ago right
maybe I can go King F6 and I keep
checking you G6 and then the idea was
you wanted to hide to H6 yeah but then
you go King
h8 uhoh give me my
queen I'm not giving it to you I'll go
Queen E5 and I'm still fine but but yes
I see what you're saying now you can
again check in eternity right okay let's
just uh update the current position and
this is it we just have Queen H1 on the
board by the way that does put the
kabash on both Rook F1 as well as Rook
A8 so don't blunder The Rook but you
have to make a
move and Rook F2 seems like a fine
square there's no way to I mean to to
check you and pick up the Rook right
you're just going to stay he you're only
going to be able to check on light
squares yeah and both players have only
one minute to go but it looks like
ashita okay she's giving this check but
there is just no way to improve the
position yeah you can't check in such a
way as to pick a The Rook what is the
update of Hans against Andrew game how
close are they to uh to the 50 move rule
well guess what you got 10 moves to go
10 so Hans one back to the king to H4 H4
so good trip for the king but nothing
there so let's go back
right and uh by the way in these types
of positions where the King was on H4
some time ago I might I would have just
go in the Arbiter say I'm claiming being
a three
move repetition because I want to make
sure that we haven't reached this
position before three times but all I'm
doing is giv my opponent a few extra
minutes which I don't really care about
but I get the information of I at the
how many more mov do you right that's
what I mean I getting all of the the
information I need by the way Bishop uh
was a discover check against the king
Andrew just said go ahead do your worst
uh excuse me what am I what am I doing I
take the oh my Bishop's hanging oh boy
good morning St Louis sorry the bishop
on E7 is under attack and I was just
having um a discussion with myself about
King takes H5 it's so easy to blunder
out after five hours of playing you know
it you know
it wow but it looks like Hans will have
to go back with that bishop and is is
time a factor in this game I mean
they've been playing much no six minutes
for Hans five minutes for Andrew but
again only seven moves to yeah and it's
very difficult to change the position
actually yeah I well I have to tip my
hat to Andrew I mean because he's he's
defended extremely that was a brilliant
defense yes yes no this this was not
easy H was putting a lot of pressure all
throughout the game he tried everything
he threw the kitchen sink at Andrew just
couldn't move
him and again from the opening that uh
Hans had he's going to be very upset
with himself that he allowed uh the
Escape because when we came in we just
barely sat down in studio and we go what
is
9796 and you you've given the Central
Pawn Duo uh White having everything he
wants Pawns in the center development
great space for for one little trick
right now don't go Bishop E6 attacking
The Rook why he lose after Bishop F6
that's a double check I got my to G7
finally I got my to G7 I got everything
wanted but King G6 and Bishop F7 is the
way to to hold yeah
yeah okay and again I'm just going to go
back for a moment with
ashria
what ashria did pick up the Rook check
this out she managed to get a check in
attack but you canot pick wait what what
what
oh that's I mean yeah I mean it's a
that's really good what she got but yeah
even this is not enough oh that's is not
enough that's so coel oh my goodness so
I can take the rug but I can't Checkmate
the king uh versus the
queen yeah I can do
this takes
Queen check for a second I got worried
for arena because this queen is coming
closer Queen G4 and this is the maximum
now I'm not threatening anything other
than this as white but I don't have the
quiet move with my king you know that
we're we're so used to seeing
uh
so draw
there let me just refresh the board as
we see Queen G3 check on the
board King H7 King H7 yeah or King H6
just don't go King H five I think
that take the P I'll take that PA fin
with both hands give give me that PA
give me that Pa thank you very much okay
this seems to be going
towards for those of you who are joining
us late my goodness was this a crazy uh
adventurous rook and pawn ending and uh
we're
just amazed the outcome of this game as
it started from what we thought was a
completely losing position for arena and
she uh somehow managed to trick her
opponent and then that rook and game
where we didn't know it one moment who's
playing for win right right what a
roller coaster ride uh Queen D3 check on
the board I'm going to go back to the
Hans demon game because how close are we
again to the 50 moves five moves five
moves away it's a countdown it's a
countdown yes it's The Final
Countdown is that time of the broadcast
I guess we're getting a little
ropey is that time of the broadcast okay
but that's why we have defibrillators in
the
room we're going to lose our comment Co
commentator there's no friendships on
the chess Port there are no friendships
or in the commentator Studio there no
friendships on the chess board right
chess is life and life is brutal okay
now E6 is a
threat wow it's taken Hans this long now
we go Bishop F7 and then we get back to
the rookie 6 Rook E8
plan why don't we play Bishop E6 Bishop
E6 also works okay just wanted to be
sure that uh if your threat is E5 E6 and
Rook G7 mate wouldn't it behoove me just
to stop you from making that advance and
Andrew says the same
question bishop
e66 and four more moves for
Andrew King
G7 you cannot take on
H5 you get
checkmated yeah that is
just that would really be the bolt from
the blue
right Rook C6 on the board by the
way Rook
E7 there's just nothing hunts can do to
improve the position Sterling defense
Sterling again he he tried for so long
but it's just not happening right
now it's like the immovable object or
something yeah no that's that's truly
what it
is Rook to E8 back Rook A6 Rook E8 back
just as you
prescribed move 110 two more moves to go
wow and I wonder if at that point
chrisberg
intervenes I don't think so I think the
Arbiter is forced to interview intervene
at move 75 but that might be Blitz rules
because I know that there are certain
differences between the classical chest
rules and Blitz rules yes I I I think
recently they changed that and now he
needs to intervene but we're not sure
we're going to find out very soon I'm
curious to see I I thought that you know
Arbiters should not intervene they
should wait for uh the players to claim
three four repetition or 50 moves rule
G7 finally giving Andrew one more chance
to take on
H5 come on take on H5 don't you want my
Pawn you've been trying to take that
pawn for a long time and isn't that move
isn't aren't we now there yes right
Andrew can write down his move and stop
clock uh I think on our server uh our
our software said yep boink our software
said draw I mean yeah and Andrew just
Lees is just claiming it as a draw as a
draw that's
it and Hans Che looking as if I'm
shocked we have the confirmation
yes
hunts looks a bit surprised yeah like he
doesn't think it's 50 moves
right 60 moves they shake hands that's
it uh and we've seen our slight smile on
Andrew's face well deserved because he
held a very difficult position so you
just have to say Well done but by the
way that does mean six draws out of the
six games today maybe Sam Shanklin
missed opportunity against Sam Sean uh
but that's backto back days of six draw
things have slowed down in the open
section but we still have one game left
so we have trying to win that end game
against enena Crush but Irena is
defending very well
also okay I see a check on
Isa has only 22 seconds
who H okay
okay
uh King E5 was it somebody forgot their
clock recently in a very important top
level game yeah I mean it
happen yeah it happened quite a few
times in the chess 9 Al that we hosted
here in St Louis Gary for got a couple
Gary
yes L as well but okay those were rapid
games to start with
right but laner gets so close every
single no when he when he does it with
one second he's always at one second I
don't know how he does it my heart just
kind of stops you know like it's the
longest second in chess like I don't
know how he manages uh to do that uh and
not you know overstep the time
control by the way this looks even more
simpler now we don't pardon me Arena
does not have to play King G8 now she
can play King G6 and force the Perpetual
check by playing King to G6 and King to
H6 just be careful not to go to F7 right
that's the last trick kind of is putting
there so this is the Perpetual I'm
mentioning because I'm threatening the
queen but the one thing he don't want to
do
oops wow that would be
painful and uh King G6 on the board and
I think right now we're going to see the
final
repetition wow don't go to F7 yeah
that's it that's that's the painful
Square just don't go to F7 so three
decisive games in the l section no
decisive games in the open so all the
standings are going to be remaining the
same in the open but I have to say
watching Carissa and beum uh win their
games and that they Lop excited the
games that Carissa won today was just
overwhelming as was beam's game I mean
they had no they had no troubles
whatsoever in their games it was really
impressive uh dominating victories Arena
was very wobbly in this game and I think
she'll look back on it and be fortunate
to to draw on it absolutely
yeah King H6 yes we're going to see the
repetition
soon
that's it both
ladies finally get the realization that
they both Miss chances yes and they know
that right they both Miss chances Arena
had a good middle game situation and
even as they entered the first time
control she was doing great mhm she
could have converted she should have
converted she did not and she will
definitely be up upset about that but at
the same time this end game was
completely losing for shria to play
Knight E6 takes F4 that was really in
and what a long game almost six hours
game
right there's going to be a new book in
check how to wear out the
commentators and it's going to be
co-authored by Hans
nean disrespect the commentators and and
uh wear them out
commentators
yeah all right don't go to H1 come on
ashita please don't go to H1 with the
queen I just to repeat the it's time
it's time I think it's
time we see a slight smile from asita I
think she's done
crying yep
yep
they King to
G6 so at last they're making their
three-time repetition I think we can
pretty much wrap up our broadcast after
uh this repetition but you got to give
us the final word on today uh think of
something very clever to say absolutely
let's uh let's as usual that final
handshake
right none of the ladies want to claim
the draw right how many times have they
done this every okay uh is is is it time
yes yes checking checking she's writing
down the move she wants to make and then
she stops the clock
yeah yeah and chrisb is like
sure I'm not I've never seen armor so
eager
that fastest checkup that pris bird ever
gave in his career it was like a nod of
appreciation thank you
ladies that was funny and let's just
take a look at the open standings if we
wrap up this the seventh and last round
so we have Fabiano Carana leading with
five points out of seven Hans nean clear
second with four and a half points and
then two players Wes LOL and Lenard
Dominguez tying for third and it's a two
horse race in the ladies section in the
ladies section we have k s and beim to
janov at 6 points out of seven they have
a one and half Point difference to third
place arena crash and Alis Lee that
they're running away absolutely Arena
came into today's round in clear third
but now she's joined by Alice who won
fourth game in a row uh-oh where we're
being told uh-oh well well Alice Alice
you guys are doing well but Sabina I'm
not sure it's
enough nice and in the well
okay wait a minute the one time I
actually
uh back get it up nobody cares no get it
up not bad not bad final thoughts
Christian wrap it up for us please well
in the ladies section it's pretty clear
to understand who favored uh who was
favored in this round it's beim and it's
Karissa who are the winners of this
round not for the simple fact that they
won their games but their nearest
competitor Arena Crush lost half a point
so that's extremely important in the
open section is not that clear but I
wouldn't call this a a neutral round
either because Hans had a great
opportunity white pieces completely
winning out of the opening this was his
moment to take the full point home and
potentially equalize Fabiano score so
Fabby definitely will be feeling good
tonight going into tomorrow's round
because he dodged the bullet in that one
he tried with the black pieces but it
just simply wasn't enough still
everything to play for in the last four
rounds and we'll be here to call it
absolutely Christian thank you so much
Kate thank you so much it was really
really great a tough long long battles
but that's what US championships do uh
you fight to the very end
measure really amazing day day seeing
just those games by Karis say and beg
janova and Alice Lee dominating
performan great calling the shots here
thank you so much for sharing your day
with us uh tell your friends and family
where you've been hanging out and we
will see you all tomorrow good night for
now bye
[Music]
everyone
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is
prohibited